you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
perfect hey what's up everybody my name
is thomas dopeziolo welcome back to the
dope as usual podcast i am with marty
o'neal what's up what up marty sweater's
super dope i just want to point that out
what's up guys how you doing this is the
dope as usual podcast we're here to talk
about life problems drugs
accomplishments and everything in
between
today's guest is someone you have been
asking since the time we said hey we're
going to start a podcast yeah this is
the josh
custerman episode thank you so much for
being here oh i'm [ __ ] off thank you
for hanging out with me that's the first
time i've ever said your last name yeah
i know it's all right that was weird
i've never said your last name to
anybody yeah how you been man thank you
for coming thank you for being here
thank you for taking the time i know
you're not here for a very long time so
thank you no this was so important to me
man i want to support you more than
anything i can't believe that this is it
this is [ __ ] amazing thank you i'll
try to stop cursing so much my
daughter's gonna yell at me but yeah no
it's just okay this is awesome thank you
man thank you so much for being here
real quick i want to start this off by
saying
the way i look at it
is you could essentially call yourself
like oh well the willy wonka of rolling
papers the willy wonka fun you are the
key holder to
what everyone else sees what everyone
else gets to get exposed to you know
what i'm saying so when i see your
videos yeah i see you doing everything
it's like you're going to get peak the
bts the stuff that's coming out soon or
the story behind what's coming out soon
you know but before we get straight into
raw yeah question where did you grow up
we've talked i've known you for what
eight nine years old i think man right
yeah i was a child when i met you i was
a little kid i just just started
drinking legally when i met you so
where did you i've asked you before i
know we wrote before our audience where
did you grow up i started i grew up in
manhattan um and from there we got to
long island for a little bit and i came
back to the city because i got thrown
out of high school in long island yeah
and then i came back to the city to
finish up high school at this kind of
really cool high school for derelicts
and i finished i got high school for
derek what's that mean high school for
derelicts you know bad people like me a
bunch of smokers you were yeah yeah okay
we call that here uh what is it called
uh
continuation school yeah that kind of
thing yeah oh okay so what did you were
your parents pissed oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah
i've never asked what did your parents
do like what was your upbringing what
was it like it was it was it was um
completely mixed so like i had a dad who
was a serious worker man like a
workaholic all the time non-stop like
full work ethic everything like that
would come from him to the point of like
he was just mostly gone working and then
my mom is she's an addict you know she
and she has been when i was little kid
she tried to kill herself in front of me
and then which was terrible but there
were some incredible things that came
out of that it gave me another mother um
an incredible person named linda patrick
who raised me from the time i was about
i guess about five until i was about 14.
somewhere around that like i came with
exactly right about that family friend
or something no no no um she was from
trinidad and she started off just they
needed someone to take care of my sister
and i because my mother wouldn't let my
grandparents fully take us under custody
and all that kind of stuff so linda came
into the house and just became like my
mom and linda raised me in a different
way than i would have been if that
hadn't happened like when you hear me
laughing and doing all this crazy [ __ ]
that's all linda linda you could
anything could happen and she's gonna
laugh about it you know
so yeah so bad things are the point of
that one is that bad things turn into
good things if you look at it that way
perspective yeah
wow i didn't know well so
did you
were you raised on like
other cultures food then is one of them
oh yeah she would go oh my god
ethiopian food and like i don't know
about that and you're telling me all
these things and yeah yeah try it right
this is trinidadian food it's different
but it's um yeah just it changes again
you get lucky sometimes it's lucky you
gotta look at that way and it ends up
increasing your
breadth of understanding of human beings
next thing you know it just makes you a
different person and hopefully in a
really cool better way
that's the goal for everything i think
every experience is if you're worse
it's not working you know what i mean if
you're not bettering yourself i think
every day
it's a stagnant life yeah not fun yeah
and you gotta and it's all again it's
that way you look at it though you gotta
i try to make myself of course i [ __ ] up
but you try to make yourself look at
okay what's the benefit in this like if
something terrible happens i miss my
flight well you know actually what what
actually might have been happening there
is when i was on my way to the airport
for that earlier flight i was getting
hit by a runaway [ __ ] truck and
crushed to death and this just saved my
life oh how lucky i am that i missed
that flight holy [ __ ] it's the only way
to look at it
why did you get kicked out of school
um the last straw was i got caught
smoking pot in the dean's bathroom in
the bathroom his bathroom his own
bathroom his private bathroom yeah in
his office no he had left the key in
there and my friend andy kaplan took the
key and went around we both i think we
did together ran to a store and got the
key copied and then they came back so we
have we've keyed our own bathroom we
thought that was so cool and andy tells
me to meet him there's this isn't me and
he tells me to meet her one time and
bless out this [ __ ] giant like i
don't know the two foot bong look smoke
yeah that was so that was the end of me
in that school he brought a bomb to
school yeah in a trench coat and into
the dean's office
to the bathroom yeah
check it
no someone smelled it and told him and
they came in there of course you're
smoking the [ __ ] bong it's gonna
stink yeah
josh i didn't know that you were this
kid when you were younger oh yeah i ran
i rode my motorcycle through the hallway
with the helmet on thinking they
wouldn't know it was me because i took
the plate off they knew it was [ __ ]
me they only killed the motorcycle and
[ __ ] the other josh
so you didn't get kicked out for the
motorcycle no
they couldn't quite prove with me they
knew it oh so it did work yeah it worked
sort of they knew it was me though you
know they [ __ ] knew with me what did
you get out of that i don't remember
what did you get out of like [ __ ] it i
did it i did it
i [ __ ] did it
that was the only cool thing okay hold
on i think it's been five minutes let's
let's light this okay let's light this
up i know everybody's like how is this
not not smoking so that right there oh
gee use this in this car and it's really
[ __ ] funny that it works so well yeah
it does it's really funny for everyone
out there can you tell them what the
hell that is yeah this is the catcher
and it has this is the new version with
the rubber clamps up here so it's more
smarter because our joints were too fat
right the original one i noticed that i
get feedback from everybody i realized
oh can make it better that was v1
actually on that first one it said on
the box because i knew it wasn't right i
wrote on there prototypo like there was
a prototype because i knew that it
wasn't going to be perfect at all but it
was as good as i could get it without
any more feedback so we put that one out
i got a bunch of feedback and then we
made v2
you're one of the only people i know
that asked me for feedback and then i
see it change oh yeah yeah i'm trying to
ask me for so much feedback on certain
products i'm like oh it burned a little
fast or this one doesn't work our joints
and that was our thing like our joints
don't fit yeah because og rolls you
don't go geez yeah and it smokes those
so we kind of can't use that
so what were you doing because there's a
story for everyone out there there's a
story behind every single product
this one was i need a [ __ ] ashtray
attached to my channel no it wasn't that
it was passing the um the cone to my
beautiful wife every night and white
sheets and no matter how i passed it i
would ash i'd be like grinding off the
ash okay take the hit get lit good good
good here you go take a hit honey give
it back to me [ __ ] ash on the thing
guess who gets blamed
me yeah it was like it became an
impossible task to keep the ash off that
damn white sheet yeah it was not
possible so i started thinking about
inventions it was like okay i need like
a [ __ ] bib i'm gonna hand it to her
on a tray all these different things so
finally it was i realized i needed to
make essentially this and first we made
them out of metal we like bent metal and
cut it and tried it and it worked so i
kept making better ones and different
ones and bowling it and stuff and then
it would i found little problems with it
you just keep evolving it again i can
keep rambling all day and i'm going to
try not to do that
eventually gets to a point where you
turn it into a product you find a
problem you realize that you're the one
to solve the problem you got a solution
now let's [ __ ] do it and then we pull
it off you're 24 7 though i mean how
many products you said you have 500 at
least 500 raw ones alone jesus
so real quick i'll hop right into this
you were getting kicked out of school
you're getting in trouble
for everyone out there looking at you
now inspired as hell yeah what was the
first job you ever had
hmm
first job i had was a stock boy at a
pharmacy i hated being a stock boy man i
[ __ ] hated that job all right so i
got thrown off a teen tour my parents my
dad put me on a team tour what does that
mean like a bunch of kids get together
they stick you on a greyhound bus and
you go camping and stop at places yeah i
know i wasn't into doing it but i was
like you know i don't know you went yeah
you had to you got to have to go i don't
know i was really young and i got kicked
off for having something i shouldn't
have had with me on the tour
and that was me getting rude off so come
back that you got to pay me back for
that teen tour you're getting a job so i
got a job at the pharmacy making three
dollars and 14 cents an hour yeah
so you sit there working for 3 and 14
cents an hour and the good thing about
all this i learned a lot right first of
all i learned how much i hated
like that when the big truck would pull
in and oh you're downloading sorry no
one else showed up unload the truck
today yourself
all these [ __ ] diapers diapers
diapers for three dollars and 14 cents
and i'm sitting there thinking to myself
this is going on wow i would gladly pay
someone else
three dollars and fourteen cents to do
this for me man this really sucks i'm
selling hours of my life
for three dollars and fourteen cents my
friends are all over the beach right now
smoking hanging out having fun i'm
sitting down here offloading this truck
for three dollars and 14 cents i really
don't like this at all
and i started looking at it as hours of
my life that i was selling and how much
would you sell an hour of your life for
how much is that how much would you pay
later on to get that hour back it's a
[ __ ] up way to look at things man it's
not a good path to happiness but there
is some good that comes of it but i
started looking at it like that as i was
working that whole summer there i never
quit the job
i i just
it changed my mentality about things and
realizing i only had so many hours to
sell and i was selling them way too
cheap way too cheap i never thought
about it like that
well when i realized was when i worked
at mcdonald's and i'm like wait
i'm getting like seven dollars an hour
when i put five in on a blunt it's more
than half an hour of my time
that's when i went no no i got to do
something else
yeah it's it's a until you figure it out
you're stuck
you know your brain will stay like no
it's three dollars now i'm gonna do 400
hours in the next three months and
it's just you can't get nowhere that way
i mean you can if you have multiple jobs
still it's still hours of your life it's
not worth it but
it's life we have to do it we do have to
do it
it's just
if you look at it as hours of your life
i feel like you increase the um like you
know you're no longer willing to give it
away it's cheap
and if you're not willing to give it
away is cheap and no one will pay you
what those hours are truly worth then
maybe step three right maybe you find
some way to make it worth it so either
you're doing something you [ __ ] love
therefore you're not looking at it that
way anymore because like you know i'll
spend hours and hours hours doing
something i [ __ ] love it i'm not
looking at it like i'm selling hours of
my life to that or dedicating our life
to that i'm enjoying every moment of it
you know it's um so there's that or
you switch to doing your own thing
in such a way that you're making so much
money and doing so well in what you're
doing that again you don't mind doing it
at all it's worth it man
you know so one of those [ __ ] lawyers
that sells hours in his life for ten
thousand dollars an hour that kind of
[ __ ] you know any one of those kind of
things
fine
but if you love what you're doing the
way i prefer to do it if you really love
what you're doing you won't look at it
the way i looked at it when i was
selling hours of my life being the stock
boy yeah
i'll film for 12 hours a day sometime
ago it was great it was great you don't
miss it you don't want any of that time
back no way it's fine yeah maybe we
could be more efficient not tell stories
in between
like that's what i do it'll be three
hours later like oh [ __ ] we gotta get
out of here but that's a great way to
put it out what would you buy how much
would you pay for that hour back later
is a [ __ ] up way to think i know it
was true because there's so many people
just went oh
i'm sorry i want to bring positivity i
don't work never no but in a way of like
it hit him yeah because if you think
about it that way how much is your time
worth
maybe i won't go get that job maybe i'll
start that business that i wanted to
that would be ideal you know that would
be ideal this is why i
really despise large corporations
because of that because of that because
they they stifle creativity they stifle
entrepreneurial high rents i hate that
[ __ ] high real estate i hate that [ __ ]
because you can't that makes it where
you can't do as easily what i did which
is rent out a little store for 450 a
[ __ ] month that opened up a little
shitbox store
when costs go up so much that that store
is now four thousand dollars a month to
rent then how are you gonna do that man
it's true it stifles the entrepreneurial
spirit which is part of the human spirit
i think
it's a good way to put it yeah right
that was a good that was a good way to
put it so you
did that the teen stop tour yeah you had
to get the job yeah that was your first
job and that's when you realized this is
not going to be i'd rather pay somebody
else to do this yeah this sucks okay so
what was your next job from there
would you go straight to the business
aspect yeah well i i always even when i
was a little kid all right i'll go back
a little further there go for it so a
little little i just remember the
parents fighting about money so much
like so much that it inspired me to make
a bunch thinking that it would solve the
fighting that was going on as a little
kid you're thinking oh my parents always
say if i could just make money then they
wouldn't fight anymore right so you
think that you're wrong but you think it
so i remember like little josh like
little guy was on the corner selling
flowers at like at the age of seven
um
selling lemonade every weekend trying to
find some little cute little hustles to
make money back in new york so i
remember doing that real clearly
the first job though was real job was
that
um i always later on after i realized
how much i hated three dollars and 14
cents an hour always started finding
side hustles to make money some of them
were completely legit some were not as
legit but one way or another there was
always a side hustle going on more jobs
yeah i used to i was
some reason i ended up in ice cream a
lot i was scooping ice cream i worked in
a like an ice cream shop i worked at
haagen-dazs i worked in two months i did
man there was gelato places which is
like more of a spatula that you kind of
take the stuff out and you put it in
you're on it that was great i worked as
a cabana boy once yeah and the [ __ ]
little shorts and the whole thing no way
in new york in new york and i lived in
one of the
extra cabanas i called it the storage
cabana it was an extra little cabana i
was 16 my mom threw me out of the house
so i needed a place to stay so i lived
in this [ __ ] cabana for the summer
yeah i loved it it was great for the
whole summer the whole summer i [ __ ]
loved it i loved it so rent free yeah
free great summer yeah great story
meeting older ladies
nice you're you're nice josh like well
thanks for the tip i know
that sounds like a cool summer it was a
cool summer man wow okay so did you go
to a question after you're done with
high school did you go to college yeah
yeah i did oh you did where'd you go
i'm bigger head hold on
respect
spidey
that's better all right so
i would kind of float around schools you
know because i was in new york at first
i wasn't ready to leave new york so i
went to some college out there called
hofstra and then what new york will do
to you is you get to a point when you
realize that if you don't leave in this
particular window you're there for the
rest of your life right so as it got to
be that time between
sophomore and junior year i was still in
new york and i realized oh [ __ ] if i
don't transfer out of here right now i'm
just here
and as much as i
love new york
it didn't love me as much back then i
didn't have as much to offer new york i
look at new york as like a living
breathing creature
and
i didn't have much to offer her
so she didn't really like me being there
so she was kicking the [ __ ] out of me so
what she likes you to do and i always
look at her as a feminine just because
of the way that i that i personalize the
city you know what i mean maybe it's
because you look at it as your mother or
girlfriend or who knows what it is just
my own personal way of looking at it i
didn't have much to offer her she wanted
me to leave and come back when i was
ready so i did i left i transferred down
to the university of florida in
gainesville which was also great because
my dad had gone bankrupt by now and we
couldn't afford to stay in college and
down there because my i was partially
raised my grandparents and i had florida
residency which meant i could go to
school for 49 and 11 cents per credit
hour which is [ __ ] cheap right so i
just had to get a job to pay for those
credit hours crashed out with friends
all that [ __ ] and managed to get through
college
so it kind of it was
a good move it really worked out and
that's where i eventually graduated from
while i was still in school i opened up
my first little store
in florida in florida in gainesville
florida like a smoke shop little smoke
shop yeah
so
before we go into the smoke shop when
did you first
find the pl like this plant that you
would one day just love love and just go
off of 13 at a bar mitzvah in new york
13 raider
night before the raider super bowl yeah
really yeah who was it i know you know
the guys i don't remember i don't
remember at all i have no [ __ ] passed
you a joint i just remember it wasn't
like that at all i found something the
older kids were playing with and i found
it after they left and like i made a
point of finding because i could see
they're all playing with it and they're
all so excited so i went over there
right as they left and i got it what was
it i can't tell you man it was something
awesome oh
okay
so that's the first time you smoked that
was the first time that i enjoyed
something that was awesome okay okay
all right i like the way you put that
very vague way of putting a very uh
professional
way of putting them
all right
so 13. 13. 13 ever since yeah pretty
much yeah wow okay lesser and then more
and then more and then more
that's exactly what happened i was like
13 to 16. like i've got no money
whenever i can and then after that like
oh god
no it got bad but
you opened your shop at what age
oh gosh i must have been
21 22 years old
all right so 450 bucks you open your
shop my little [ __ ] it was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
box i love that story though as big as
this room yeah same size this room yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so you walk in
you're the guy they see at the front
yeah because i was living there that
picture
yeah yeah
yeah that's the big shout out
man you have the cut off shirt yeah the
cutoff shared i've seen that that's a
good one so i was a rolling paper
collector i loved rolling papers so like
my dad used to do magic tricks with his
when i was a kid and it made me fall in
love with rolling paper so i was always
collecting always collecting when the
internet came i put my collection online
right and i'm trading with all these
collectors in europe and i was the only
american that had the balls back then
you know what i mean just they know just
say no but i put my collection online
anyway so the europeans love me because
i would send them like
rolling papers that i considered to be
garbage from america and they would send
me back really cool european [ __ ] so
when i opened my store i kind of next
leveled that
and started building a business off of
that where like i would send them what
again some stuff that wasn't the
greatest and they would send me back
some really cool european papers and
sometimes they had the old stuff
when from when papers were made a
different way and they would send me
those i loved those and my customers
loved those and the other thing i
learned was
there was like a going rate for rolling
papers in america back then it might
have been a buck a pack so it didn't
matter what i paid for it as long as i
sold it for a buck a pack so the
europeans sometimes i would send them up
like the stuff would cost me like 15
cents and i could still charge a buck a
pack i was like holy [ __ ] i can actually
make some money on rolling paper this is
awesome and everybody's happy because
the paper itself is much better smoking
in my humble opinion the dude's happier
i'm happier everyone's happy except for
the big company that isn't making as
much money in america who still hates me
to this day but yeah other than that
everyone was doing great
so that's when i realized that there was
a business there all right so i had the
idea and i recognized it
that's how this started yeah
really so in the smoke shop it wasn't
just papers it's all walks of life all
that kind of stuff yeah any kind of
smoke and stuff i learned all about
tobacco any kind tobacco products i had
[ __ ] everything going on because the
goat was really about smoking
it really was
and i i learned i learned so much from
the people that came in i built the
store around the customer so the dude
would come in think what people make a
mistake out in business is they have an
idea and they think they're right right
and then they kind of push their idea
out there
what i know is that i don't know [ __ ]
right so i know i should open the store
but in the end i need to listen to every
person that comes in and let them tell
me what i should have in the store or
what i should be doing so every person
that would come in they would say hey
man you're opening a great smoke shop
this is awesome are you going to carry
dugouts for example and my answer would
be like yeah i'll have them within two
weeks what's your favorite one they'd
tell me all about i'd really have an
engaging conversation learning
everything i could about from that
person about dugouts then they would
walk out the door and hit the phones
calling up until i found that particular
one they wanted and if
they wanted i assumed some other people
did too to get a whole box of it bring
it into the store see what happens and
that person would come back two weeks
later there it was so the store was
really built by the community and this
isn't just about this one store though
this sort of mentality can be propagated
into anything you're doing if you're
really listening to people it's the same
thing you're talking earlier but you and
i were talking that i listened to every
single thing people say yes because i
know that i'm wrong i know that i don't
know that much i know that i'm here to
serve people that's my job right yeah so
the best way i can serve you is by
talking to you and figuring out what
your needs are and sometimes i have to
do it without you even telling me which
is harder but i can do it and figure out
okay how can i make this better for him
watching you smoke that i saw how many
times you relit that thing and my mind
as you were doing i was thinking how
could i make that better for him how
could i make it that wouldn't happen
what could i do what could i do and i
had some ideas but it's um yeah
this is what i do yeah and this is
this is what you do
as i'm watching you like that over and
over and over i'm realizing that
something's wrong what is it how can i
fix it and then i'll come up with ideas
of how i can do
it wow so this started
your love of papers yeah started because
you saw the market
the love of paper started when my dad
were growing up in new york
during the holidays my dad would take
his rolling paper this old spanish brand
called marfil arose an old spanish rice
paper which he would light on fire and
throw in the air in front of me and all
the other kids
and would vanish
and we were like oh
so that made me real like it
i don't want to say this it made me
realize because it's true that rolling
papers are magic
and i still look at them as magic to
this day that was the only magic trick
he knew but it blew my [ __ ] mind and
that moment that was it
so i've been drawn to it from that point
i was probably five but drawn towards
rolling papers from there
and
it just set me on this journey that i'm
still on today
wow
i did not know that that was [ __ ]
awesome
you've done that in front of me you know
that right
yeah yeah look at how this burns see
that black stuff from my dad it's
different
you've shown me this dad's magic trick
man that really set me on a path for
life that magic trick came back to me
years later i mean because of my
collection i get called in to have a
meeting with a man who's looking for
he's reopened what we believe is the
oldest rolling paper factory in the
world in alcoa spain right it's a region
of spain and it's where rolling paper
i'm pretty sure was first ever created
first ever made and there's nobody left
there except now it's
my family but it used to just be him
and he had reopened essentially what was
this old factory called propelladus
reunitas which was this reunited family
of rolling papers from all the little
houses that had come together to make
one real factory to stand together
against the giant factories that had
opened elsewhere
and they held their ground for a while
until they were destroyed through
litigation which is a whole other story
by someone who still dislikes me a lot
to this day and sued me too but that's
another story um
and
i had a meeting with him with the man
who had reopened this who had done this
and he
he sat with me and he was this beautiful
old spanish man and he's looking at me a
whole meeting with his arms crossed like
this sneering at me because i'm sitting
there and i'm you know still in my 20s
and i'm still me
so he's looking at me like
and he asked me in spanish and
thankfully i know some
why do you even care about rolling
papers josh
and i turned to him and i told him the
story of my dad and the mafia rose and
he got so excited and told me josh i
made marfila oh wow my father made my
filler rose my grandfather my great
grandfather had all made marfili rose on
his wife's side and it was he was like
we must do this again
and we decided to bring it back
and the way we brought it back because
even the brands were taken back then the
brand names we named it elements after
the elements that are used to make this
beautiful rice paper
and that's where elements comes from and
that's that shows you the connection of
the journey like one thing leads to
another to another
it just goes on i know that's what you
need to elements and for everyone out
there yes
make elements i made elements for my
father it was his favorite paper and it
still is
wow
what a story
that was amazing yeah i felt like i was
in the movie right now you do a good job
with that sorry man that was a good
storytelling man that was no because
when you tell a story and you know this
from being a podcaster the reason
if you allow yourself to when you tell a
story you relive it
right which is why old people seniors
which i am one of now um like to tell
stories so much because it gives us the
chance to relive that experience so as
i'm telling you about jose emilio i'm
sitting there feeling it again the way i
felt when i'm sitting there across from
him i'm feeling remembering that look at
my my dad's eye and my my friends so we
looked at each other as their own paper
went up and vanished
all that stuff you get to relive each
moment of it when you retell the story
that's true every time i tell a story
i'm not even there i'm just thinking of
every single thing that happened right
and i know i'm staring at it from
everything
that's how i tell no i got so lost right
now so
one you are the creator of elements for
everyone out there that does not know
that yes juicy j's also yes why did you
make juicy j's that's the flavored
flavored paper yes flavor papers was
there was two reasons one you want to
know where the name came from or why we
made it both
okay name the name first is because
at one point in time my dad was making
some money and he was i love that man i
really do and he got me a mustang
convertible right and i'd i'd been
making a little bit of money working so
i put gold rims on it and i was all
excited right
right
we're going like folks but yeah yeah
yeah
we're going to like 88 now like 87 those
kind of years right that's a long time i
know right before you report it's okay
and there i am in my badass mustang
right and then suddenly vanilla ice
comes out and he comes out with a with a
song and he a video where he's driving
one that looks just like mine
and it's like oh god this [ __ ] killed
it bad so it used to be the car was cool
for like a couple months until suddenly
when i pull up there i'll be like
vanilla ice is here
[ __ ]
why did i pick white out of all colors
[ __ ] it's a badass car though it's a
badass car man with a 5.0 it was great
five speed people that's that that
people are dying for that car yeah fox
body yeah i see him so much oh i worked
on the thing all the time i wrenched
that [ __ ] i got [ __ ] it started off
with 225 horsepower i got up to about
280 by the time i was done with it i
loved that thing man i really did 280
was a lot back then especially the money
i had which was a lot so i managed to
get with every little trick to get the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up adjusting the timing by
turning the [ __ ] yourself all that stuff
it was fun
so um there's this mustang right so one
day me and my friends cut school and we
decide because we were big fans of ll
cool j and in his song he sings you know
farmers boulevard that's where i hang
out this words cool app man the place to
be we just thought we're going to go
down farmers bowl or we're going to find
out where ll cool j hangs out oh sh
dumbass [ __ ] kids you know what i
mean where were you how were you 17 i'm
thinking oh okay okay you can you can go
out there on your own yeah
no
we're cruising down farmers boulevard
stopping at people popping people at
intersections to ask them you know where
little cool j hangs out we are such
dumbasses right such dumbasses yeah
here's his address follow me yeah we
were so dumb we didn't know we were 17.
so we pull into the place where everyone
hangs out that night i pull into my
mustang right and there comes the usual
people making fun of me yo vanilla ice
is here like no no no that's not vanilla
because everyone had heard now what we
had done yo that's not vanilla ice
that's cool jay's staying man ask him
where he hangs out like okay cool so i
got this nickname of cool j from there
not because i was cool but because i was
a dork
and so that's where the first flavored
rolling paper we made
was menthol and i named it cool jay's
after that [ __ ] nickname i had back
then and then the second one i made was
watermelon which i couldn't call cool
j's because it wouldn't make sense so i
named it juicy jays like a juicy
watermelon you know to signify the
flavors of the paper
and that's where it all came from this
nickname turned into
a rolling paper brand i love that all of
these have a story they all it's not
just you're just putting words going you
know these mesh
they all come from somewhere it's like a
[ __ ] story time that you smoke
i'm holding back right now because i
will like i'll try i'm going to see if i
can do this in a nutshell the cool thing
that happened was because that old
factory propeller unit had been
bankrupted when jose emilio started his
factory he was only able to get the old
machines only certain specialized
machines that the people coming from
other areas to destroy the old factory
thought had no value they didn't just
want to take the machines the people
that came they wanted to destroy it the
thing they were told is let not a seed
stand or it will plant and grow
right they were splitting machines down
the middle
just to destroy it a competition had
been going on for hundreds of years
hundreds of years
like the kind of stuff you watch on hbo
of clans fighting with each other over
rolling papers over rolling papers
this has been going on for a lot and it
still goes on
this still goes on
there's nothing the fight our land
it's like that man what this is what
it's like it's crazy
but the way that people have looked at
it because if you did something that
your father did your grandfather needed
a great great great great great great
great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great
great
great
great
great
great great video
you're carrying a grudge from six
generations ago
you know and your dad taught it you hate
them right they like them we hate them
we hate them we hate them and that's the
way they think about each other it's
it's like a different type of
competition that's
generational generational grudges man
for real
oh god so they wanted to make it where
there'd be no more rolling papers made
not quite ever again middle
yeah they split machines these beautiful
butterfly machines they cut them down
the center yeah split them to make sure
they couldn't would never operate again
trash them nothing nothing was allowed
to be remained but jose emilio knew this
was happening so he took all his life
savings and he bought whatever machines
he could get the ones that weren't
claimed yet and all he got were a bunch
of old awesome machines and some of
those machines could make flavored
papers in a way that still i don't think
anyone could make flavored papers the
way that he could or that now we do
and
this is what we had if we play with what
you got
negative to a positive negative we had
these old these machines can make
flavored papers cool let's make flavored
papers there hadn't been demand for them
in decades let's try it again let's make
them even better and jose was so good at
this he made some incredible favorite
papers i believe that we've made the
best flavored rolling papers that have
ever existed yet in the history of
mankind that's awesome someone else will
do better later on this is an alkoy
thing when i was talking about the
multi-generational thing what you come
to realize if you spend a lot of time at
alkoy working on paper or anything is
that you are just a link in the chain
there's someone who's coming after you
someone's coming after you someone look
after him after him so your job is to be
the best link in that chain you can be
so during your time of running the show
you run it the best you can bring it to
the highest level that's ever been
brought maybe you'll be
you'll get the statue in the town square
or the carvings that you get some of the
people have gotten in the past hopefully
i'll get one of those
and then eventually someone else takes
over and your time's done
as you bring it as far as you can bring
it knowing that you've got it but
someone's probably going to beat you in
the future man that's okay you did your
job you were the best link you were yeah
of course someone's better out there hey
someone can make it better i know they
can't yeah they know they can they
definitely can especially with the
technology everything too it's with
anything yeah you grow everybody i hope
someone takes this straight and just
runs it yeah makes it even better at
least that's the mentality i would think
that people would have they should have
to have yeah yeah that's human nature
because we all get higher together man
we really do as a as a as humanity we do
if no this is my secret i will hold on
to it it was the same thing with
freaking learning how to roll i came to
realize that nobody was teaching people
how to roll
and i started why is nobody teaching
anybody how to roll what am i missing
here i went on youtube on all the stuff
and i'm looking and it was mostly people
showing off look how fast i can roll i
was like all right that's cool why don't
you teach someone how to roll and i
would look at it and maybe you would
they would teach a few instincts of it a
few little
tricks of it but it wasn't that thing of
hey can you teach my grandma how to roll
because if you can develop a technique
and show a technique in a way that my
grandma learned how to roll then you've
done something incredible it shouldn't
be imaginable that you're holding on to
so you can be the cool guy at the party
look i can roll no it should be
something that's shared among all of us
because and tell me if i'm wrong on this
one
the ones you roll yourself
smoke better
it's for you every single time yeah
because i know exactly how i'm gonna hit
it there's little tweaks most people
don't know that but in the joint there
are little variations in every piece
that's going to make it smoke different
right now i can feel right here it's
drying so it's getting a little rock
hard right here yeah and what's going to
happen it's going to fall
so you got to adjust it slightly tweak
it just a little bit
massage yep now it is a perfect [ __ ]
joint
there's a lot of i know you know most of
all you're staring at my joint going out
i know you know you knew all that [ __ ]
yeah i know you know
real quick real quick since ron i just
noticed it right now before we started i
saw your watch
it is ridiculous and i love it so much
i'm not into jewelry i never have been
yeah this [ __ ] math watch so it's the
only bad thing i wear where did you get
that
and how cause you said no save it for
the podcast the podcast all right here
we go right let's get i'm going okay
guys i'm going to tell you the long way
but [ __ ] it you're just going to hang
out with me for a while with the video
because i don't i won't get the chance
to hang out with you so now here's our
chance all right so here's how it goes
um
when i was in high school my best friend
george his dad was a was a lawyer and he
made real money and so when we graduated
high school george's dad got him a rolex
with a blue face and some little gold
links right and i was i didn't even know
that there was such thing as a nice
watch i had no clue this existed and
then george shows up with this watch i'm
just like wow that's beautiful i didn't
know that was a thing so i asked my dad
for a watch my dad gets me some seiko
that fell off a truck or something you
know what i mean
so
that was like a thing that planted in my
head and when i was still in school and
doing all my little hustles the first
nice thing i bought myself i went down
to local pawn shop in gainesville
florida and bought myself a used beat up
watch just like george's with a black
face
so that was my first nice thing i ever
really bought myself was that rolex and
i really liked that rolex because it was
mine and i had gotten to myself and all
that [ __ ] who bought it it was mine i
got it later on all the rolex guys would
pick on it because i could tell it was
made with different parts from different
[ __ ] didn't matter it was mine i [ __ ]
loved it
um in 2009 or 10 somewhere around there
i don't remember i come back to take
back over my company which is a story
for another day but i have to fully take
it back over and i'm down there and
everything's cool but there's like my
employees are like oh man your watch is
really kind of [ __ ] dude you should
get that thing rebuilt like what do you
mean and some guy takes it off and i
didn't know it's a thing with rolex's
but apparently you take it off and you
like hold it
like that
and it's supposed to hold itself up okay
and mine was like oh it's drooping
you're like fully down like they're like
dude it's going to fall off your wrist
it's going to go flying you're going to
lose this thing you got to get it fixed
like what is it what does that mean like
oh it needs to be this you send it to
rolex they'll do it i sent the rolex and
they gave me a quote like much more than
it's worth to fix it i'm like
[ __ ] what do i do i'm like oh and it'll
take six months oh like oh okay so what
i do oh well there's some old guy you
could send it to take some of you to
rebuild them he'll charge you a lot less
maybe you could see if he'll work on it
so i speak to the guy sure enough he'll
rebuild it at least a year josh okay so
i'm gonna be without my watch and i'm
like you know what
maybe it's time to get a new watch maybe
it's time to get a watch so i start
looking at all that and all i can think
of in my mind is that one brand of rolex
because that was the thing i couldn't
have as a kid this happens to us by the
way the thing you couldn't have the
thing you'll always want right so i'm
looking at all of them and they're all
these fancy ones
i don't give a [ __ ] about any of them
all i wanted was that one so i'm like
what do i do what do i do there's
nothing here i care about and then um
i think it was betty sent me
this picture of this watch that was for
sale
and
it was ridiculous it was this watch and
it was the world's only rockin rolex it
was made for lil wayne and he had put a
deposit on it but then he got went to
jail so he never picked it up and the
jeweler was trying to sell it
desperately no one would buy it because
no one would wear the [ __ ] thing
so i took one look at it and i was just
like
i think that's that's ridiculous but i
think that's my [ __ ] watch
so yeah so that's how i ended up with
the world's only rocket [ __ ] seen
anything like that little williams watch
it's [ __ ] awesome i know the second i
saw because i like i said we were
looking at watch i'm not into jewelry
but my friends i was looking at their
stuff and
i see why people really like it it's
[ __ ] amazing when you look at like oh
my god okay i get it i get it it's just
like i put new rims in my car like
okay but i'll break stuff i'm [ __ ]
animated and i'll break it yeah i'll
destroy things too that's why i'm like
i'll just stay with my joints and i
break those too so i had to ask it is
awesome looking yeah we saw it earlier
but i wanted to save it still the only
really nice piece of um of jewelry that
i own everything else is stuff that i
make that i love because i make it
myself yeah the joint rings you can
smoke through it i love all these rings
by the way all the rings you can put a
joint in and just smoke it marty
look at his face
look at his face this is my newest one
this is my favorite it's a double barrel
put a joint in it
just hold it in your hand nice [ __ ]
awesome these come in really handy so
there's a story behind each piece right
so this ring the raw toker's ring was
meant for
i kept getting cup cough in the clubs
man i kept getting it you're passing the
cone around everyone someone in your
circle has a cold and is lying about it
oh no i feel fine
here you go josh
thanks for the cold bro appreciate it
and i kept getting sick in new york city
and i was tired of it i was holding it
doing all the weird holding method
through the side but in the end i was
still getting sick so i decided to make
i wanted a holder
that i could like
put it in yeah so now whenever i need to
whenever i'm in the clubs you'll see me
whenever it's time to smoke it's always
like someone's passing me it goes in
here i light the side for a little while
first to kind of sterilize it then i let
it cool down for a moment and then i
smoke through the ring and i have not
gotten cup cough since nice yeah so it's
always like
awesome
it's your own personal filter
i do this one
i just go like this
because i go with candidates
i know it's cannabis cups i just i it's
hard to not be rude when you go up no
thanks man
okay you're right you don't you don't
understand you that feeling of uh
nothing hate turning them down yeah i
hate it it makes me feel so bad it's
like hey you want to hang out
i'm like i'm too good for you that's how
i feel oh yeah i will totally smoke with
you when i get together i just don't
want to get sick i don't want to go yeah
don't give me that cold i don't want the
cold please don't give me the cold yeah
that's what the rings are for us now
people passing a stick in here and
they're [ __ ] awesome yeah so
we we started touching on it and we
stopped
you saw the market you saw the people
coming in asking for different papers
your love for papers yeah the magic
trick
you go there he's starting his new
machine are you starting his new spot
they cut everything down the middle that
was exactly what you started yeah they
destroyed everything he had already
reopened the factory but he was having a
lot of trouble selling because no one
appreciated the paper besides like there
were 10 of us that really actually
appreciated this old way of making paper
this old style
which is very
rustic compared to a modern rolling
paper factory
and
you have to be more of um someone who
loves paper to appreciate some sewer
yeah you have to be at a real high level
it's like the difference between charmin
and like a craft paper like on a reel
that you open up and has a scroll inside
you know it's like you're looking at
that kind of difference where it's like
but yet how do you teach people to
appreciate this
so we just kind of we just went with it
and
is this how you started raw with him
yeah oh yeah
so he saw you and you saw his
opportunity like oh i can have my own
now oh so we made elements we made juicy
js but the dream i'd always had was to
make my own uh real rolling paper back
when i had my store again everything's
connected man
you still have the store while doing
this oh no no back when i had the
storage oh gotcha or actually i might
have still had the store while some of
this was going on but i don't remember
exactly right man
so
um
when i was in my store in the early days
of the store again people are coming in
tell me what they want one guy came in
and told me hey are you going to carry
and he said a certain brand of natural
cigarettes a very popular brand nowadays
i try to save certain brands
and i was like sure yeah of course man
i'll be here in two weeks what's your
favorite one whole thing i normally do
get them in for him in my mind because i
love paper so much i know so much about
paper i've studied it now i really
understand a lot about this stuff i'm
picturing based on him sitting there
lecturing me for 10 minutes about how
his cigarette is so natural i'm
picturing him to pull out of the pack
it's going to be this translucent brown
natural paper of course it's going to be
it has to be based on how everything's
going to be natural
so he it comes in i sell him his pack he
opens it up he want one of course man i
love tobacco by the way that's terrible
but i do and he pulls out a cigarette
hands it to me and it's a typical bright
white bleached freaking full of chalk
cigarette
and i'm looking at this thing like
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] just looks like a damn it
could have been a marlborough it looks
exactly the same with everything else
and then i realized i thought about my
collection i thought about the history
of rolling papers and i thought about
everything i'd ever learned and there
had never been the type of rolling paper
that i was imagining
and then i'd think about okay why isn't
there that's a whole nother story why
has there never been that paper oh i
really that's stupid it's it's because
when we first made rolling papers i say
we i mean humanity it was to people were
smoking out of rolled used newspaper
they were re-rolling cigars that had
literally come over from crystal
columbus days to
to spain these old cigars and they would
be open
the aristocrat would smoke it halfway
down and then it would do something
called turning which means it gets over
resonated and it gets so bad you can't
smoke it they would drop it on the
ground the peasants would come and grab
it open it up re-roll it in used
newspaper and then hit that and then
hold in the puffs because each puff was
still so precious it was coming over on
wooden sailing ships in the you know i
mean
columbus type days yeah
now this thing of rolling in newspaper
makes its way up to alcoy which was the
paper-making capital of all of europe at
the time another story it has to do with
the moors bringing paper there first
and you know this dude i really i could
keep it here for days
really days
and it wouldn't end i got you
so when the alcohol saw this they
decided to make a bright white bleached
paper to show that it was pure
that showed that it wasn't used
newspaper they literally marked it as
hygienical to say that it was
a pure paper and they sold that as
cigarette paper so to this day whenever
you see a bright white paper and wonder
why people are using it it all goes back
to alcoyona's trying to show people that
the paper they were making for smoking
was not used newspaper
and back then newspaper would have had
some extreme heavy metals in it you
wouldn't have wanted to smoke it
damn it's like hundreds of years
hundreds of years stories i just got
lost again yeah i was going down brick
cobblestone right now in my head that's
exactly where i was it is it's like this
man like i try to i i'm trying to hold
myself back because i could tell too
much and i don't like
i could sit here we could tell stories
till the end of time and i and
honestly i want to because i want the
whole world to know what i know i want
this information to be shared i want it
to be out there so that we all enjoy it
more when we realize where we come from
it helps us go in a better direction you
know and you recognize where something
came from it just kind of
you know more about it and therefore
you're able to make it better when you
make it you're able to enjoy it more you
laugh about it when you know the story
of the invention of this it makes you
enjoy it more and you get oh that's why
and then next thing you know you're
saying to me you know what you should do
josh you should and i'm like really
okay thank you for that i appreciate it
i'll do that it's um it's like that it's
the sharing of knowledge we used to do
around the smoke circle telling stories
and just sharing information now you're
at the head of the down circle man and
you're sharing information with everyone
and now your circle's getting bigger and
bigger your whole podcast audience is
just to me is just one big smoke circle
and we're all just hanging out together
sharing freaking stories it's exactly
what we've said before
that's exactly what it is no matter what
the camera is you you're at home just
chilling yeah that's the point the whole
point of this is exactly why we did this
we said uh
exactly how this is why we started this
because there's some people that are
sitting there by themselves going
oh now i got someone to chill with yeah
yeah yeah every week
yeah it's just another friend added to
your hangout list that's how i feel
especially during the pandemic oh it was
the worst
was the worst it was bad for people so i
was on live every day for hours just
trying to like
remember names remember profile pictures
get on p because you know some people
were not having the best time
a lot of people aren't personable they
don't really go out i can only imagine
like me in high school when i was a kid
if i was doing the panda it would have
been the worst thing in my life i had
never talked to anybody in life right
and it's just
it's not fun you meet how many people
doing countless meet and greets i don't
know i know there's people telling you
their story and you're like
well that was awesome yeah so happy that
this made your your day and your life
just by me
being here and i know you know this
because i've seen you do it it's so much
it makes everything
better doing it it makes your life feel
worthwhile for like it gets me high man
when someone's telling me oh my god you
changed my life you saved my life and
i'm like okay how and they actually have
something to say that i'm like
holy [ __ ] that's freaking awesome i feel
so good about myself and i feel so happy
you know
it's just it uplifts it yes i'm so glad
i helped them and then they just helped
me
and it's [ __ ] beautiful man so that's
why they always say the secret of life
you make other people happy then they'll
make you happy it's true
you bring other people up you get up to
but that is amazing that you i did the
same thing as you during the podcast
i thought it was going to be 21 days so
i decided oh i'm gonna i literally went
on the first day i'm like it's going to
be okay i'm going to share with you 21
different rolling secrets and techniques
and
it's going to blow your freaking mind by
the time this is over you're going to be
a better roller and you're going to do
so many smoking tricks right and i
taught them funny [ __ ] that i was
busting out [ __ ] from a long time ago
man i was doing gravity bongs i was
doing freaking the apple pipes i was
bringing like old old old [ __ ] back
every day funny stuff you know what i
mean the waterfall where you punch a
hole in the bottom of a water bottle
yeah
all the old stuff one a day and it was
funny 21 days and then it kept going
that's two over two years ago then it
kept going then i was like wait it's
getting hard now wait a minute it was
supposed to be 21 days it's not there's
not
there's not a hundred smoking tape trips
you can get so no you start running out
after a while but wait a minute there
are ones but they're not as good as the
the early ones because busting out my
fun and stuff i really had funny just
really making an apple pipe after all
those years my first one i ever made was
two years ago i've never made one before
it actually worked really good i know it
was kind of it was kind of awesome that
i never i felt stupid for all the times
i'm making canned pipes oh no no there's
no extent of the worst pipes oh
especially melting all that paint yeah
oh my god yeah you know yeah you know
yeah um it was the worst but i know we
keep gotten off topic i'm so sorry so
you made raw after all that you decided
i had never seen anything like this at
least that was the dream in 93 i think
was that was when the dream came out
that was when i realized i needed to
make this i had no ability i was a dude
with the store i was happy to be a dude
at the store but that's all i really was
i couldn't go make a rolling paper but
the idea sat with me so then we made
elements and then we made gcjs and i'd i
knew what i actually wanted to make i
developed enough i don't want to call
when people trust you more enough credit
whatever it is credibility right
incredibility credibility yeah
credibility i developed enough
credibility where i could finally go
meet with the mills the mill owners
these are the guys who make the bulk
[ __ ] it's not rolling paper yeah you
take pictures of yeah the giant well
sometimes not even that some of that
stuff's already been processed somewhat
i'm talking about like oh we've only
seen the process stuff i don't know i
don't know anything about sure which one
is facetimed me once and it was like
that already been processed yeah they're
either watermark
yeah those are huge yeah but that i
think the ones i showed you that had
already been through through some of the
machines
so
it's um it's like the paper itself is
rougher when it's not ready yet it'll
look similar but it's not it's not what
i would want to sell it's not even if
you tore it open and smoked it it
wouldn't smoke right could you light a
paper on fire and know what's wrong with
it
could you smoke it take one puff and go
i know what's wrong with this paper
sometimes yes sometimes yes um i i would
rather if i throw in the air i'd
actually have more trouble looking at it
so when you said it to me if i was like
i'd rather light it and look at it and
watch it burn in order to get an idea
for what might be wrong with it i've
seen you tell me like look at this yeah
how it's burning right this because this
this this this this explain to you yeah
that's insane man you down down down to
a science it truly is 100
this is what you
live and breathe so who else is going to
tell you different when you burn it
usually i've watched you do it before
yeah so what are you looking for say
you're burning something and what's the
chalk for everyone out there here's the
psa why you shouldn't be smoking
anything that's bleached well it's okay
i can't tell them not to do anything
well if you said
a healthier alternative would it be to
smoke organic papers is a healthy
alternative then those the dudes with
something with some other papers will
assume you're saying okay you said your
papers
why do i like smoking these more than i
like i can tell you that regular old
white paper beach white papers okay so
a typical bleached white paper isn't
just a lot of times they're not even
bleached with chlorine but they're still
whitened they're still processed right a
lot of the a lot of what i call the
naturalness has been taken out no
different than necessarily white flour
or something like that just a lot of the
stuff that i want to stay in there is
gone
and because of that it's going to
perform differently it's not going to
burn the same way it's not going to hold
together the same way it's not as close
to nature as it was before you blasted
it with a bunch of chemicals one way or
another
or even if you bleach it in the sun
which i don't really know anyone that
does that
so another thing that was developed
unfortunately for all of us i think was
the addition of chalk to rolling papers
this was again because we started off in
that line of purity of saying that white
is purity now it's your ash needs to be
white too well how can i make your ash
whiter i know
i know
that's why i will add chalk to the
rolling paper i'll grind up calcium
carbonate one way or another could be
the nicest calcium carbonate in the
world lab grown doesn't matter it's
still calcium carbonate i'm gonna grind
it up into a powder and i'm gonna add it
into the paper mix one way or another so
that when the paper burns down what's
left behind is going to be chalk dust
essentially essentially and leaves this
beautiful white ash there wow that looks
so nice doesn't it wow this is the
purest paper i've ever smoked look how
white that ash is oh yeah that's so pure
bro
so pure bro so it's a it's a it's a fake
trick
i can't say it's fake what i could say
is i call it bogus
okay it's not your ass should be if you
want a white ash it should be white
because of your material not because
someone added something to your rolling
paper or added something to material it
should just be naturally inherent
because of material i think and it also
depends on whether i want to chase that
white ash people think that white ash is
better what does white ash actually mean
it just means a more complete burn
if you can take a i can take a beautiful
plant that will burn white and i can
over humidify it just a little too much
so that the moisture content goes up so
not as much of it burns off and it will
darken the ash because not just not
quite the complete burn which some
people would say i've heard some
arguments of some people saying that the
darker ash because it's not as a
complete of a burn that it's actually
better for you because more of the bad
stuff is left in the ash so now we're on
this whole other kick of like which
one's better which one's worse yeah i've
heard it both ways that argument yeah oh
i heard because we talked to scientists
about this and when they're telling me
this i'm like oh crap i'm like another
argument
i'm not going there because it doesn't
matter to me you know what matters to me
that people are happy but i do want them
to have at least knowledge and
information understand what's happening
so they can make a better informed
decision for themselves if you want to
smoke chalk there's nothing wrong with
it but you should know that you're
smoking it you should know it's in your
rolling piece like actual chalk that you
write with it isn't it's well
just grind it
the really good chalk that you get that
you get that i if you buy a brand called
full touch which is like the nicest
brand i've ever seen yes it's just pure
calcium carbonate which is chalk um
which wouldn't be so different than the
calcium carbonate that you add to this
or the calcium carbonate that's in some
other like products
i think tums for example oh really yeah
and and really there's i'm not saying
anything wrong with it it's just when i
when i read the msds on it it's telling
me that getting chalk dust in your mouth
and lungs is an irritant and causes more
coughing and irritation so and maybe the
embassy is wrong maybe they're talking
about giant quantities don't sue me
again but when i look at this and you're
when you're someone like me who's trying
to achieve the highest level of the [ __ ]
that's ever been done in the history of
humanity you're gonna look at this and
say if it has the potential to [ __ ] with
me and [ __ ] with the product and the
experience i'm trying to get with people
then i don't want that anywhere near my
freaking beautiful raw rolling paper
let's keep it away from there it could
be in the tip i don't care nothing
that's going to be burned though let's
get it away from there
really because i want to give thomas the
best experience he's ever had and what
if that alters his the profile deters
what if it changes things what if i
start using other things like
galactomannan derivative and things like
that to create just yeah if i start
adding things to the paper to make it
cheaper or make it even perform just
differently or maybe even better i am
how's that going to affect thomas when
he smokes it what how's he going to feel
about that i don't think he's going to
want that i don't think so maybe i'm
wrong but i'm not going to put it in
there so i'll just let me just keep it
as simple as i can keep it and give
thomas the experience that i feel like
thomas's great ancestors would have had
when they were essentially throwing
things on a fire and breathing in the
smoke you know like you're trying to go
back oh my god dad you put so much
thoughts
i don't see how other rolling paper
people
wouldn't get pissed
like this [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
guy again
give it away our [ __ ] secrets
but you're not you're kind of just
educating people on why your [ __ ] is
better i mean before i knew you
i started buying raws and smoking
because i tried them once yeah i told
you before i started i went to a smoke
shop straw uh smoke and j's in merced i
saw cones
said combs
the [ __ ] does that mean the guy
explained it to me bottom went home
packed and went get the [ __ ] out of here
there's no way i didn't just have to
roll a joint those were the first of its
kind right that didn't i don't know is
that that's the first people to make
cones
the co
those types of cones the ones that i've
made
there's a man a very smart awesome man
named arthur who oh i made my first
cones back in 93. mine were different
than what you see now arthur made cones
that were more like this in starting
around 94 95 yeah 94 95.
so he opened up the world's first
commercial cone factory i used to make
cones i had um underneath i lived in a
three-car garage above a three-car
garage i had my own bong factory
underneath for my stores yeah you just
made glass yeah no no no it was all
acrylic back then we're talking 90s man
it was before we had glass yeah we made
glass later on but at first it was just
acrylic
yeah you would buy the acrylic tubing
from like a pool wholesaler and you
would blow it out cause making a dowel
you'd heat it up with a hot with a heat
gun and kind of make the little blowout
you drill through that put in a rubber
grommet stick in a down tube that you
would often make yourself i did not know
that you used to do this yeah i've done
all the [ __ ] like i've been doing this
for a long time i've known you for a
long time i know you did that yeah what
yeah that's where it all comes from and
one thing we made was i loved rolling
papers and i preferred smoking out of
paper and my friends would say nah man i
want a pipe because i can't roll so
finally one day i was like you know and
they would actually ask me to roll it
for them i would roll it over a pen or
something and pull it out give it an
empty there you can go fill it then one
day i realized hey i could probably make
something even easier to fill so i start
i took two sheets back then because we
didn't have the kind of king size paper
that exists nowadays i took two sheets
wet the gum lines put them together
actually no we didn't with the gum like
i twisted it all right twisted together
like this rolled it around a dowel we
had that we used to use for those down
stems and made oh it was a cone you know
and at the top of it i flared the two
the two lips out like that and i called
it a tulip not like the tulips we roll
nowadays but again i called it a tulip
because it had two gum lips you know
what i mean and it was cool and then i
stuck them in this cigar display i had
and started selling them for a quarter
piece yeah we're talking about 93 around
there back then wow and i was selling
cones back then so that was my first
experience selling cones yeah
i get why they're suing you
i understand they're pissed i'd be
pissed you if that was my competition
and i didn't like competition no they
hate me they would [ __ ] hate you i
really
that's one thing i always say i don't
know how people could
how could people hang on someone nice
you ha well if he's your competitor
you'll find a way but there's nothing
there thomas they make fun of my laugh
because because they don't know what to
do so it's like literally anything
anything [ __ ] your shoes look at your
[ __ ] hair yeah look at this [ __ ]
lap look at that clown like yes i'm a
clown that's cool yeah look at my
[ __ ] weird ass hair right wait my
[ __ ] laugh i got made fun of my laugh
in high school i'm used to it man
this is the way i [ __ ] laugh
man i totally see why i get it now you
just broke that down more you we've
talked for
i don't know how long about papers
i don't think we ever talk like this
i'm starting to see why
you give a [ __ ] so much oh there's more
to it
just i don't know i'll hold back some of
it because again i don't want to keep
you here all night but the one thing
here's how i look at it i'm going to
smoke this when you smoke yours yeah
someone smoke it together so no worries
oh wait oh wait oh is that the one way
to smoke yeah wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait i'll wait for you no okay
wait for you all right we're gonna do it
together i'll wait for you to smoke
together oh oh god okay that that way
i'll just i'll let right away regularly
until you're ready okay okay is that
what i want you to smoke that's gonna be
funny um that's gonna be funny
[ __ ] i'm scared now no it's gonna be
great i'm gonna love it
so
raw success here's what i think it comes
from and i i think i'm right
i believe that you intrinsically inside
of you know something you feel something
so if you were smoking of rolling papers
before raw
and it had certain things in the rolling
paper
that weren't
as close to nature as i would like
and you're smoking them smoking and
smoking and then one day someone hands
you a raw
right nothing like this you've ever
smoked before we're going back 2004 2005
now you're around the smoke circle with
your friends they hand it to you you hit
it
what is that
it gets passed around comes back to you
hit it again
that's different
you're not even sure if you like it or
not at first you just know it's
different but something inside of you if
it's a reptilian brain or what it is
receives it differently or just like
that
felt more right to me
you don't even realize you're thinking
it but you just do
and the next time you're in the smoke
shop
you're going to buy a pack of papers and
there it is on the shelf and you're like
you don't even know quite know why but
your
inner being brings you to the point of
that one that pack of raw i want that
one i'm gonna smoke that one again and
then you bring it home and you roll up
your friends come over and you share
with them and they have the same
experience the next thing you know
little by little through this passing of
smoke circles and the naturalness of the
experience
you end up smoking raw and so does many
many many many other people
so all this marketing all this stuff and
all these things none of it really works
what really works is this thing inside
of you that just brings you to it it
connects with you better and gives you
that
different type of experience than you
had before and you won't even really
notice it as much until you go back to
that original [ __ ] you were first
smoking and you take a couple hits and
you're like yup what not
[ __ ] like i was smoking this that's so
right i was smoking this yeah i won't
say the company they don't i won't get
so mad but holy [ __ ] the time i went
back to the paper that i originally
smoked yeah it was like construction
paper yeah like when i like the tips you
can't they're not malleable they
have edges yeah yeah when you try to
pick your clothes they're sharp edges
yeah and that's when i realized and when
i lit it and i got that first
like oh
you can't do it yeah it won't smoke i'd
smoke a bowl i will smoke a bowl over
rolling into the paper yeah and
this is before i met you guys you know
like this before i ever [ __ ] knew you
guys yeah i just i
instantly could tell that's why i was
selling hello stuff but
i could instantly tell that it was
different yeah that's like i said the
cone was the first thing it just got me
hooked because like i don't have to roll
and then i got the packs and it was the
king-size supremes oh gosh fat ones yeah
that was i was stuck on those for years
like three four years man that's all i
would ever roll because you could roll
almost an eighth in those
that's why that's why i would uh use it
yeah but that just got me stuck and
i hope a lot of people watching right
now that do use raw or and or use
another brand get to see
there's a face and there's a brain
behind and there's a story behind
everything yeah but it's not about them
what i want them to do is i just want
them to really close their eyes and
receive the smoke
receive it from a raw receive it from
some other papers and see what you like
better
you should go with what that whatever
that is if it's mine great if someone
else's great too but take the time to
really allow yourself to truly feel it
think about what you're doing you know
we were talking about terps before when
i was talking about terps the thing that
i want him to do and i want everyone to
do really is
pause for a moment take a break just
like i'm talking about the paper open up
the bag
let out let it all out first
open it up
take it in
receive the terps see how it makes you
feel
do that a few times here and notice you
receive things differently from
different types
go with the one that sends the shivers
up your brain you'll feel it come up
there go with the one that connects with
you go that direction it's telling you
something man
and that's kind of the way that paper is
and that's where a lot of things are if
we take the time to allow it to happen
this is a beautiful magical plant but
not everyone allows the magic to be felt
i don't
i told you
no when like when i when i
sit there and
how do i i've never done that in my
entire life unless i'm like my favorite
[ __ ] and go oh yeah and i'm just
smelling it i do get that oh yeah yeah
oh because it's just what i'm smoking
now this is what i've been smoking for
years because it does that yeah but i'm
never sitting here with every one of
them going
but like i said earlier it's my drug
dealer oh he's all frustrated dumping
your ace into your charge yeah now now
now i go to the stores
and buy a bunch of there's a certain
brand out there that has such clean good
that's what i'm smoking now i love it
and i've been smoking for like eight
months consistently but you know my
background what i used to do it's weird
buying weed out of the shop
instead of just going hey i'll be right
there
it's odd man it is a change but
i need to i guess i need to try that
marty too he goes i don't know i just
dump nugs in that's that's kind of me
too i guess i never really stopped and
appreciated hold on where's beans oh
yeah explain this please hold on we'll
find marty's because as we're doing this
he's gonna smoke
there's marty smarty smarties marty's
smarties okay come here
you
this is going to be great
okay
you are more than welcome
okay please explain that okay you
explained it to me i'm like oh [ __ ] that
explain it again i'm already i'm ready i
already need to get reevaluated what
what is this this is
get boosted
now it's just cause i'm trying to
explain in a word what it is
so sure we add on terpenes that's been
done before that's awesome but what we
actually add is a molecular extract from
certain plants that bind with the cbd
molecule to change the way that you
receive it so your cb1 cb2 receptors
receive the signal from this differently
than if you just smoked just the plant
and because of that especially if you're
someone like me that has a tolerance
problem
your it goes around the tolerance simply
because it's a completely different
signal so it's not being blocked or
being turned away from so you receive it
better and also it's a different signal
so it actually gives you a different
feeling inside really yeah so you're
saying whatever you have should have
some type of percent of cbd it needs to
happen
one percent active cbd for this to
really work
it um you need everything you need a
full spectrum but i need you to have
that one percent some strains have no
cbd please don't i blend some in like
these ones you're smoking i actually sit
there and blend in a really good cbd in
there to make sure that i know you've
got cbd just to make sure it's like the
cone is what the terpenes do and what
you did it activates yeah the terpenes
are are just there as an added booster
the real booster is the what we call
you'll see on there cannabinoid
activators
hacktivator
i love that i just noticed
lemon jack terps yes with lemon jack
rocker that helps rocket booster yep
i'm trying to explain what it does with
marketing and words i'm trying to
legally explain how am i gonna sit there
and explain all this to somebody yeah
you know like okay let me just sit i'll
explain to you for ten minutes and then
you go smoke like oh no i gotta get you
in five words like oh how are you gonna
go oh
you everything about it though
cannabinoid activator i think you did as
best as you could possibly do
to try to explain what the [ __ ] going
on what's what's going on
um this was v1
in v2 i'm kind of blasting you more in
the face with make sure you got that one
percent cbd
i'm just sure that's it i learn as i go
anybody can find that it's an awful
anyway anyway yeah just make sure and
and that's real strains like real
classic ones always had like eight
percent cbd things like that so it's if
you have a classic screen you don't need
to add anything it's just some of the
nuclear things that are out there they
make a point the way it goes they
increase one thing and they decrease
something else and so those are the ones
i'm more worried about we're like wait
it doesn't work well
it's really it's natural
in its own way and therefore it's
designed to connect to the natural and
when we
nuclearize things
we're kind of stepping away from the
natural yeah so like you said i would
like it to be as close to earth natural
earth as possible yeah that's your nice
way of going that shit's full of
chemicals i'll say it for you that's
just [ __ ] that's a great way of
putting it i would like it to be more
natural to the earth like
i love that it looks like a healthier
option and how you chose the branding
color when you walk in yeah it's the
colors was there a lot of
uh other iterations before you landed on
this final look that you have
yes and no it was designed like i would
picture i was raised more about my
grandparents than my parents so i'd
picture them all these boxes my grandma
would send me when she would go on trips
which was like brown paper packages tied
up in string when i was envisioning raw
you know that's where you have the
string on it that's part of it the
string really signifies the history of
rolling papers rolling papers used to
come out in a giant sheet from the from
the mill enough in the middle from the
factory and they would a fold fold fold
fold it and then tie it with a string
and that's how you would buy your
rolling papers the original rolling
papers so when you bought your first
pack rolling here the first ones ever
that were really sold were sold to like
that like a scroll
no it was folded
oh and then just
folded and tied with a string and the
original folds were done in a way to
give you a tear line that was your fold
was your tear line for the sheet of
paper and the original rolling papers
that we we humans ever first smoked were
essentially one and a quarters
one and a quarter yeah that's the
natural size of rolling paper so like
we're left to our own devices there's no
taxes and no regulations and no [ __ ]
the first thing we ever came up with was
about that size
so i always try to bring myself to smoke
more one and a quarter than anything
because i just but i know more than too
many i know too much you know any words
like i'm being infected by lessons i've
learned throughout history because that
is the natural size of a rolling paper
that's why you said i'm trying to bring
these back to myself more yeah i always
said that yeah i try to make myself step
back from king size because the tendency
is to be lazy and go right to a king
size i could stuff more in there but i'm
like no josh if you smoke two one and a
quarters you've got two fresher hits
super fun smoking two of them
having two different ones is so much
more fun
okay okay put down one and i need you to
light that one up let's go i gave away
mine but it's okay we're gonna we're
gonna smoke that i'm gonna watch you go
no no no it's better i just wanna
experience no these are i gotta fill
them then it will take us a little bit
of time these are all empty oh [ __ ] okay
okay no no no okay keep going this is
gonna be great
all right boosted cone huh
here we go
my question ready well wait before i ask
you a question just oh without you
haven't done just take it in a little
bit i did it earlier it's very lemony
but i burned it so it's different let
just feel it in there for a moment
it reminds me of
going to my mom's work at cost plus
they had all the wooden
wicker baskets and stuff that's what it
reminds me of
smells can do that to you it's one of
our strongest
equipment
tied to memory i think i said right
i'll smell something go oh my god
kindergarten class
you know we do that all the time oh
that's still but now that you did this
you already triggered your
endocannabinoid system and you're
already you've already received some of
the signal so earlier when i said i
think the ones you roll yourself smoke
better i'll tell you the story why you
start smoking that come on lighter man
okay oh oh okay i don't want you smoking
i can't wait to see because there's a
little bit of a creeper effect on this
and i want to see you go down not go
down right i just want to see you how
does he get [ __ ] up i want to see if
you feel it man i want to see you really
feel it
so you got yours going marty oh yeah
i learned when you roll something
you've now felt it you've touched it
with your hand you've experienced like
so much information that's gone to your
brain about what you rolled up
you already know the stickiness you know
the sensation of it you know if it's dry
or moist or any of these kinds of things
you rolled it up you know the details of
how you rolled it up especially you you
know you really know your details so you
know how it's going to smoke before you
even smoked it you've got so much
information now and now finally you
bring it up and you take that first puff
you're more ready to receive it than if
you just bought a pre-roll and a seal
and you open it up and light it it's
like a shock surprise
and i believe this is true i learned
this in ethiopia and all that work i was
doing there the humanitarian work they
taught me to eat with my hands more and
they insist on eating with their hands
because
they feel the food they know the
temperature of it the texture the
consistency so much about it
yeah and finally when they bring it to
their mouth they already they're not
scared of it whereas if you eat food
that you haven't ever had any human
contact with metal fork foreign stick in
your mouth your mouth it's like oh [ __ ]
is this gonna be hot cold sweet what the
[ __ ] is gonna be what's gonna be called
what the [ __ ] is that oh it's scared to
receive man you know
i've never thought of [ __ ] food that
way in my life oh it's true the more if
you every time you
touch it with your hands next time
before you take a bite of anything touch
it and put in your mouth and then take a
fork and do the same thing and see how
you receive it it's the same thing as
this when you smoke that one that you
rolled yourself compared to pop open a
plastic tube and take a hit it's night
and day
yeah
i'm gonna be eating [ __ ] foe with my
hands and [ __ ]
like josh said
oh man
you're playing this one on me no i like
this good
but i'm waiting for it to creep up on
you i like it
just waiting for it to creep up on you
it's not going to knock you down but
it's going to give you a different
feeling that's all i wanted to do huh
okay i like this
marty how's yours this is great i was
over here taking it in smelling it yeah
i like this resin ring going on
i like that that's my favorite part
about joints when they start dripping
yeah that's when you feel like oh god
savor this [ __ ]
um so my question or a statement into
question 2014
you guys are like how would you like to
be a brand ambassador and help us out
and go oh my [ __ ] i remember where i was
standing right oh
perfect circle where i was standing
remember everything it was the push
trees house
bathroom behind me to my left my [ __ ]
door to my right i mean my left
front door tv and i looked at it the guy
jason that used to run you guys stuff
remember i looked and went get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah remember where's rosie
at
[ __ ] is rosie at so it was just wiz
khalifa right and i remember like wait
did you
[ __ ] i'm excited like [ __ ] yeah i
want to be part of you guys team
so since then i've seen you work with so
many people which is
the direction you're supposed to be
going
what's the collab you've always wanted
to do you haven't done what is the dream
collaboration for you as a person
that's done so much
what's the one person you want to work
with company and whatever whatever it is
a raw
times this wrong collaboration every two
go okay first one is just because
willy [ __ ] nelson there nice
all right that's cool cause it's [ __ ]
really [ __ ] reached out to these
people i've tried to reach out to willy
i've not had good luck reaching out to
willy [ __ ] nelson really yeah i
figured he'd be right up right at the
end yeah i know i know i got invited to
his thing a couple times but it was
never personal enough where i was like
no got you i've been told like i know
people that know him they tell me
stories of how he does certain things
you know he was using one of my um one
of my inventions which was a toilet
brush
safe for real something i created don't
ask me why i make crazy you've made
other things because you're smoking
are you an engineer there's like a
background idea
so i made this toilet brush safe i
called it a never touch safe because i
knew if i you if i put this in my house
that there's no [ __ ] way that
someone's going to go through there
trying to find something you know what i
mean so i made this toilet brush safe it
looks like a toilet brush put in the
corner about the toilet ain't no one
ever going to and it's a safe it's a
safe yeah yeah yeah i don't sell it
anymore but i do i did and willie put
one on his tour bus and [ __ ] loved it
he loved that thing so i know i've
always told stories like i'm like come
on i got me will he knows me he loves my
[ __ ] he smokes my papers why can't i
hang out you made other stuff man is
there anything else you could say right
now that you made that was [ __ ]
awesome i feel like the rest development
cornballer
what else have you made
you've made a toilet brush safe not a
toilet brush safe i made some of the one
a lot of your pocket scales you've ever
used in your life the better ones are
probably for me really yeah i make some
incredible scales i know the titan
tron's uh
titans js titan titans it's called titan
or i have two triton
i have three of those yeah everybody
have a [ __ ] house i've never broken
one right
and that lid comes off
yeah it's the same should i do i know i
like trying to bring it to another level
with scales i was working on real
hardcore in like 2000 and then i got so
far with it when i kind of ran out of
improvements so i just kind of i moved
my focus away you just sold those man
yeah no no i was making a made them no i
make them i make them make them i try to
make them the best they can be you know
i'm not sitting there taking the
stainless steel trays on them and adding
a little lip that goes around it because
i'm realizing shit's rolling off and
then if something does roll off i'm
trying to catch basin somebody rolls off
and goes into there and he gets happened
to the back like i'm trying to bring it
i'm trying to really freaking
bring it and those are down to the point
yeah point zero zero yeah i love it
depending on which one you want i got
one they go to point one i got one zero
point zero zero one point there's
another one
i'm trying to bring it and you're like
i'm just trying to bring it the furthest
it can be wrong
yeah yeah i thought you just gave me a
couple like hey check these out no no no
no some of my stuff yeah oh sick even
better i love it even more now i didn't
know you made it and the tray on the
side i even said whoever made this knew
what they were making it
i love this tray there's been many times
where i'm like stacking and then those
people doing it right now and going oh i
get get a cup just kidding yeah yeah
yeah yeah i know there's a lot of people
doing it right now yeah i know i know so
you made the toilet brush and that sorry
back to it willie nelson sorry for the
rant city over here willie nelson he
hasn't reached out but he loves your
toilet brush yeah that'd be [ __ ]
great who's the other collaboration you
would love to have of course man it's
[ __ ] jay-z imagine that really yes
it's his favorite person
jay-z collab i would love to do a jd
cloud i'm working his people use my
papers for um his pre-roll like all of
his pre-rolls are done like he's got his
company right yeah yeah those are all
done in my papers and we've even worked
on either i don't want to give away
secrets i gotta be careful we even
worked on something really special with
them but i want to work with him yep you
know what i mean i get it wow those are
two great
great uh collaboration dream
collaborators who would you collaborate
with adam sandler on just life
just ha give me a high five and then
make my whole life that's fine oh come
on we don't want to high
put it down there and then you should
hand them [ __ ] handles
are you calling the brown hand or
something are you talking about mall
rats
would you like a chocolate pretzel
do you like the driving covered press
god i love that i thought you said [ __ ]
man something like
you're kevin's you're friends with kevin
smith yeah you you know what you know
mall rats god i love that [ __ ] it's a
schooner it's a [ __ ] boat stupid i
love that movie so much
um
so
willie nelson jay-z for me yeah a collab
i don't know man that's a good question
it's a good question
uh and on videos or you mean like
clothing
anything
hmm good question
a light just went out sorry sorry guys
um
i've never been asked this question
uh we
we we talked about it openly but vance
hit us up last year to do some stuff and
then just never get us back
so that was my other one like hey hit me
up and did the same thing
why you hear this [ __ ] same thing
man are you serious yeah i was all
excited i think we're gonna do a raw
vans and it just they just went cold
yeah yes
i was like all excited because i [ __ ]
love fans no hopefully they'll come back
to both of us it's my favorite shoe dude
if we threw all three of us together me
you and vance i would [ __ ] love that
that would work
[ __ ] fun oh my god so that'd be my
collab yeah vans and adam salad
my favorite shoe ever
hey what's up guys welcome to the
mineral ad read and this episode is
brought to you by miller lite
all right guys let's get right into this
if you go right now to
www.millerlight.com
forward slash yola that's going to give
you a landing page to every place in
your area that delivers beer to you but
if you want a miller light right now go
to any place on earth that sells beer
one of the things i always say what does
miller lite remind you of to me it
reminds me of hanging out with my uncle
some of the best times of my entire life
and it's the nostalgia is what makes me
love this beer and for all the health
nuts out there 96 calories per can 3.2
grams of carbs once again you can go to
millerlite.com millerlite.com forward
slash ola brings you right to the
landing page shows you all the places in
the area that delivered to you as i said
before and i'll say it again if you want
a miller lite right now go to any store
that offers beer since 1975 miller light
has been brewing beer for people that
just like beer no games no gimmicks just
beer for people that actually like it
once again guys please celebrate
responsibility from the miller brewing
company in milwaukee wisconsin as always
thank you so much for supporting the
brands that support us it's miller time
let's go
oh man so good all right i love this
question marty is switching the cameras
i have a question
from marty then i'll i'll move on to the
next one real quick
um
you're you said you did the work in
ethiopia i know a lot of people like
what are you talking about yeah so you
started your foundation and in ethiopia
you're doing the well water correct
water wells water wells water wells now
i have to be careful about this with the
foundation so the foundation is not a
501c3 it's not that tax hedge thing that
you see people do where they set up
what's called a charitable trust or
whatever the [ __ ] something like that
and they could put money there and get
big tax write off it's not like that at
all like the money we give we actually
give
you know so it's not like i don't want
to call it a foundation where because of
all the bad names from donald trump and
hillary clinton all their foundations
[ __ ] for us it's really about giving so
now i call it raw giving to make it
clear that what we do is change we can
give i thought that was just like a like
a slogan you guys went with no because
it used to be raw foundation yeah now
i'm just now i need to make it clear as
to what we're actually doing which is
actually giving you're not taking a
bunch of your [ __ ] money and putting
away there for a tax it's you have to
give it
like if it's given it's gone
there's something i once i once read
from marcus aurelius which said the only
wealth you ever keep is the wealth you
give away
because once you give it away it can
it's gone
so like so i learned this you know
because i went through the [ __ ] with the
feds with the machine gun to the head
and the handcuffs and the whole thing
and because once you've gone through
that [ __ ] you know i mean with the guys
with the helmets and all that [ __ ] once
you've gone through that you realize a
lot of this is very it's not just
temporary it's like
beyond temporary at any moment now the
feds are gonna come back through that
door right there they're gonna kick it
open they're gonna put me in the
handcuffs again down on the floor the
machine under the head the whole [ __ ]
thing take away everything i ever earned
for papers they'll find some way man who
knows they're saying this happened to
you already oh yeah over papers happened
to me over i sold a bong to the daughter
of the united states customs service
special agent in charge for the northern
district of florida and she was 18 but
it was still my store's fault i didn't
do it myself my store did it um it was
my my fault for selling her that pipe
not her fault for buying it and he came
in with a bible in his hand and the
machine guns and all of his friends door
flies open the whole thing like full on
kicked your store in oh yeah came full
on in man full on house store everything
he threatened to shoot my great dane
because my dog's barking at him you know
i mean just like it was [ __ ] awful
just awful because you just legally sold
this girl a bomb right well it was
illegal the bongs are illegal back then
this whole [ __ ] oh the
um reference
oh you got played before chong got
played yeah played a few years later i
didn't realize bongs were illegal at one
point yeah yeah water pipes like
water pipes they're not bongs oh man
if you heard them argue they'll say they
still are i don't believe they are
because of the weight of loss by the way
good i'm glad you like this yeah i'm
still waiting for the creep on you a
little bit you'll like it more in a
moment i like this so you got raided
because of that
but it's not about me getting raided
that's cool it's about the experience of
getting rated made it where i look at
things a lot it's a lot more temporary
it doesn't mean i got to make money and
throw it away quick it's like i laugh
about things like all the all the
millions of dollars that we've truly
given away truly given away
right that's important
yeah look back on that and the cool
thing is
it's gone i could be living under a
[ __ ] bridge and i still did that
there's no losing that got that totally
feel that yeah i did it it's done it's
over
[ __ ] you
oh he didn't really do it yeah but i did
i was there i was there i was there
i've seen it i know it's done right i
drank from the well bro it's there
you're building well i mean you're doing
you're doing way i've seen you guys
building buildings so what is exactly
what is your
goal when you went there versus
right
right
okay fine first goal when you went there
was to start what's your goal now that
now you know what you're doing you met
these people you know by name you know
these kids you see them grow up you've
seen them go to school
what is it now what's the goal now one
hundred thousand one hundred thousand
people i wanna save one hundred thousand
lives before i die that's the goal with
that through it doesn't matter how and
saving them could mean
actually saving them they were going to
die or making their life so much [ __ ]
better that you pretty much saved their
life right um getting girls keeping
girls from being raped um terrible [ __ ]
like that fistula which i really would
is that
like it does
when
some and i call them my because we work
this is areas that i work in some of my
people
might be forced to have sex when they're
too young and a tear happens between the
anus and vagina and it causes an
infection and or maybe even have a baby
too early and having the baby too early
is actually even more common um
before they were ready to have a baby
again it causes tearing and something
called fistula where essentially the
poop goes into the vagina oh and you end
up with terrible infections and you're
going to die from this so
how do you stop it well of course fixing
it surgically afterwards is something
that you do but preventing it from
happening in the first place is
so much better right so how do you
prevent it from happening in the first
place well you got to get the girls
working more you got to get the more
power you got to get the more control
you can't have them walk to that water
well because they get raped on the way
to the water well the guys know they
walk to that water well every day what
if they don't walk to the water well
anymore well
okay pump it up here solar pump down
there send it up to the village now the
girls with the with the
exchange with the village elders of when
the girls no longer have to do this they
must go to school
yes we will get we will sign this
contract saying that yes cool so now not
only did you bring the water to the to
the village but now the girls are going
to school and you're kind of breaking a
whole cycle of
something that are you getting pushback
from people that don't want that there
no good no we don't get pushed back in
that regard some of the work we've done
against
uh just female genital mutilation we've
gotten some pushback but it's um i don't
care
i'm still gonna fight
like how much i gotta fight about but
it's to be like no next we'll we will
bring you this water we'll do this and
you will sign this that there'll be no
fgm here ever as long as that water well
is operating
and they're like
no no okay then no that's the only way
this will happen do you have a whole
section
is it is it
towns is i don't know villages villages
is it just one village or you have like
a
a certain diamond going to areas of
greatest need so you're floating around
gotcha that's where i was and it used to
be like one village at a time right
you'd go to one village you'd put in
what's called an afrodab 5000 hand pump
with a great hand pump it needs some
maintenance you'd put in the water you
drill hit the water put in the pump
create a well commission where everybody
that uses it pays a little bit of money
just to help maintain it some one person
you teach how to really run it and they
have to teach other people how to run it
as well sorry if i'm talking too fast
you would you would create a little
community around it and you would leave
and there's your well and it's done and
you come and check on it if they really
need your help they let you know and you
develop a system for that it used to be
done like that now because of lower cost
solar now it's one central well
somewhere where there's really good
access to water and then you'll solar
pump that water to eight villages
and then and you do it in a way where it
just runs on its own there's no one
there's no switch to turn off
sun comes up water starts flowing into
storage tanks that are at those each one
of those places if the storage tank
overfills the water runs over that's it
you better use all that water
okay then the crops are being planted
around it and it just runs on its own
down at the very base where the main
thing is there'll be somebody one way or
another that is really in charge of just
protecting that area just making sure
that no one comes in to try to steal the
solar panels or something like that or
tries to charge their phone off the
panels which is something we've dealt
with there's lots of stuff like that you
deal with and it's just okay it's all
part of human nature you just have to
make sure that everything's fine
wow how many have you done
dozens man dozens
we've done so many of these projects now
some are huge like the ones we do for
the sisters of mother teresa or we i
think we've done all of their hospitals
now in ethiopia i think like um wells
there like there were seven compounds if
i remember right there's seven compounds
throughout ethiopia for the sisters of
mother teresa and i believe we've given
water to all of them at this point it
started with just one and then i
couldn't believe it was me man like i'm
saying it like oh yeah i'm just doing
water with us with his
thomas this is me and you man no i know
so imagine if somehow just for the
[ __ ] miracle of fate and weirdness
and who the [ __ ] knows what you end up
you have the responsibility of being the
primary water giver for the sisters of
mother teresa in ethiopia
hospitals that house 800 people at a
time worst conditions you ever can
imagine within the depths of like a
horror movie and now you're responsible
for getting them water because they
don't have water
cool how you gonna live with that man
right so you deflect it you can't really
take it in
you can't really accept it but then you
just sit there and you kind of step out
of yourself and you feel detached from
it because it's a lot of responsibility
to bear and you didn't want this
responsibility but it was given to you
by the universe what are you supposed to
do say no you say no you know what
happens yeah i know what happens it
ain't going to be good the universe is
going to smack me silly it asks for this
we do this we are humans we stand up for
each other and we do it and we do it as
good as it can possibly be and then you
don't just [ __ ] do it like unix i'm
sorry i'm getting set i get mad at um
certain united nations organizations
that do these things where they build
these beautiful [ __ ] walls of getting
angry i don't want to get angry um
they build these beautiful things for tv
where they put in a well with a kid's
merry-go-round on it so the kids will
play on it to pump the water and as
they're playing on it sends the water to
a tank over there and it's all this
really cool stuff and then they take
their pictures and their videos for cnn
and [ __ ] and then they leave
what do you think happens
how you maintain this thing man
come on be realistic yeah
you didn't develop a water use committee
you didn't do what needed really needed
to be done here did you create a
sanitation system for them did you teach
them about digging toilets did you do
anything like this no you just made some
really cool stuff that looks great for
you and you left
and now i got to come there and pick up
the freaking pieces take what's left of
the stuff and just throw it away throw
it out
use the original thing you dug and use
that attach onto it with a normal pump
and teach people how to use
realistically how to how to use water
from here and how to share it correctly
and and then i got to stay in touch with
them so that when
the pump really breaks and they didn't
have enough money that they saved up
themselves that we can go in there and
do a repair project and get it keep it
going
how long have you been doing this
it seems like over five years now before
i moved here
much more than that i don't know what
year we started this stuff it's been a
while now i want to say
2014-13 probably before then yeah yeah
cause it was it came with um
i have this theory that like
with every gift comes a request
so i was on a i was working in this
vegan charity called earth save
and
it was i just remember we had this
incredible year at my company where he
made a bunch of money and more money i
never thought i'd make my whole life and
look at this like holy [ __ ] it was after
we accomplished a bunch of stuff like
the launching of raw all things that
people said could never be done
and i'm looking down and at that day if
i remember right maybe my mind changes
it a fax came over the fax machine
that's what it was like which was a plea
for help from a town called dekicha
ethiopia
where they
cros they had no rain at that point for
more than a year and the crops had had
died the animals had died and now the
people were dying and they were refusing
to leave and it was a plea for help
and i looked at this
and it was really i think it was the
same day i got the results telling me
how well we had done and i didn't know
how to handle that because i can't and
just being honest i can't man i can't
so it's a weird feeling it is i can't
handle any of that stuff i look at it
i'm just like oh people tell me these
great numbers we do and i'm like okay
cool that's great all right so let's go
back to you know just just go back let
me make something really cool let me
teach you a new way to roll i can handle
that my mind can accept that
and
i looked at that facts and i thought to
myself
i can solve this man
if anyone can solve it it's going to be
me i just did that look at those [ __ ]
numbers we did there's got if there's
any water in the area i can get the
water there's got to be a [ __ ] way
and that set me on a journey that i'm
still on today
we got them water we saved that village
it was awesome and that set me on to
another one and another one and they got
bigger and bigger and then you're there
visiting and you find another thing and
another thing
and another thing i'm on a little bit of
a soft spot at the moment because during
the and i'm going to call it a civil war
in ethiopia at the moment one of my
projects that i knew wasn't good it was
in trouble got blown up and it got
really hurt badly and some of the people
i love got really shocked one of them
got shot
i'm sorry and it's a it's a place where
i was thought i should have been there
i could have could have held that
[ __ ] gate thomas no i get what you're
saying i could held that [ __ ] gate i
know it could have held the gate
i mean there's not much you can do when
you're you don't know what's coming yeah
yeah i knew
i get what you're saying man
but also
you're what's making everything work
you know what i'm saying you you're the
the key holder yeah you can't hold the
gate open and something happened to you
then what happens after that
i know it's a weird way to think about
it but that's kind of how it works
that's why people have security the main
person is because that person makes
everything work and then everyone else
is affected after that point if that's
gone
so it's not like we need to save them
for ourselves but it's more of like
everyone's gone if you're gone yeah you
know what i'm saying
i
i i know and i give myself consolation
with something that
uh sister morello once said to me when
she was talking because when i was
leaving there the first time they said
in afar say oh i was in afar dewey dawa
and i didn't want to leave
i had this feeling
i was like i just i looked at this area
i looked at these beautiful people
the sisters and all the people they were
helping and look at these beautiful
people and they're so much more
beautiful than me
you know looking at their lives they've
given their life to help others for real
not the kind of [ __ ] way that i do
they really [ __ ] literally
here
and i'm looking at this rickety [ __ ]
gate
there's a dude there with he's got a gun
ain't much of a gun it ain't much of a
gate
it's like
and i'm looking at this as we're leaving
and i'm like i can't leave you to this
there's some really bad people on the
other side of that gate i know they want
to come through
and
they're telling first of all they
wouldn't let me even stay the night
because they they're like you'll get
kidnapped tonight no you can't a war
zone out there like that right now yeah
you're on the edge you're on somaliland
essentially so yeah you're in some
you're really in you're in the [ __ ] you
know
it's incredible most beautiful place
but it's there's some serious things
going on
and
so
and i had the conversation the
conversation was something like
you know i want to stay i have not done
anything compared to either or thank you
i haven't anything compared to what you
do
and they're telling me
josh if you don't you must go if you
don't go do what you do then we can't do
what we do we have no ability to make
money we don't even know what this is
here
this is
anyone can give their life not anyone
can do can i help us the way you have
and you're like okay so you take that as
strength and you take it as motivation
and then you go you're like okay okay
okay okay and you walk out that gate
knowing full well that you wanted to
hold that gate you wanted to sit there i
told the guys i was like i really wanted
to make a call and call but i don't know
why i was going to call dale one of my
guys and be like i need you to send guns
and a lot of ammo a lot
you know we're going to hold this gate
right just right water thing
that's the whole hospital the whole
compound oh oh oh i thought i got you i
thought you meant it was like the pump
that they were coming to do no they're
coming to the whole thing yeah
it's religious problems
although other things
the sisters are not the same religion as
some of the people that are around them
and it just creates conflict even though
they're just there to help it still
creates a point of where is it going to
be a there's a potential flash point
yeah
right now current day current day when i
was what last time i was there before
that they were crying because
i don't want to go negative i don't want
to go i got you i got you in another
place they were at um some bad people
had come in and killed all of them
except for one sister that hid behind a
door that was open and she was in a
little crack when the doors open and so
in yemen
so it's um
things happen man yeah when someone's
really angry they have no one to lash
out against they latch it out against
whoever they can lash out against
the representative in their mind the
closest thing they can to whatever
they're angry about
well you're doing everything you can do
man yeah
no i'm not no no everything you can do
while maintaining everything else
yeah because there's going to be a point
in your life like we talked about we're
like
i can hand this over i can hand this
over and i'm going to do something else
yeah like you're saying maybe you can
spend more time there how much how long
are you there you're going i see you
every time i call you you text me back
or call me four days later just got your
call just got your text how you doing
i'm like oh you're in ethiopia oh you're
in spain yeah i know you're somewhere
else yeah i know you're somewhere else
you do a lot though yeah because before
we even got into the foundation
that's a lot on your [ __ ] plate as it
is just to maintain yeah you know and
then maintain
all of that is another big step
and i think uh i wouldn't feel bad man i
think you're doing a good job i think
you're doing a great job more than most
people or anybody i've met before okay
i'll say one last thing before i cut you
off on nothing i don't accept what
you're saying because i know that every
little piece even this beautiful watch
if you go into this mindset which is a
terrible mindset to go and it's not a my
it's not a journey towards happiness
with how many people you could have
saved if you hadn't bought the wall you
get it if you hadn't bought this you
hadn't bought that and it ends up
weighing on you with each thing you buy
you're like wow how many people could i
have how many people go to handwritten
google and it sends you to a spot that's
hard it's a hard place to be happy i try
to get out of there man and i do a lot
but there is that point that holds on to
the back there of like it's you some
people would call it guilt i call it
more of maybe it's just grounding i
don't know try not to look at a negative
way it's important to realize that
everything does come with a cost and
that's okay man but then when i'm
working when i'm working on a project
when i'm making something when i'm doing
stuff it does add weight to the process
in a good way where i'm like no i got to
make this i got to make it as good as it
possibly can be better than anyone
that's ever made it before in the
history of [ __ ] humanity and i gotta
bring it out there and it's gotta be
success so i can do even better so yes i
can give back more and i can [ __ ]
even bring it and i'll be even better
person that way we're gonna go guys
let's go
and my team's like okay man let's do it
again you know then we end up down that
road
so you can you use it in a way to
motivate
that's always that's exactly how i see
it like that's what i was trying to say
but you said it better
you're the puzzle piece the better you
do the better everyone can do the more
you can do yeah
i know you're saying like well i have
this watch well also you ate food today
and yeah you did other things and you
have a bed
that beds a thousand dollars you could
have gave
it's a never-ending cycle yeah it never
ends but also
you're helping as much as you can yeah i
mean you're helping you also are a dad
you have other things in life besides
you'll have that time man you're giving
that time right now and at a time where
you don't have it to give yeah yeah yeah
i know so don't you know i mean i know
what you're saying i know what you're
saying like i can't accept but also
in the back your head know that you're
doing what you can right now
i mean
you're you own a business you're doing
multiple things yeah you're inventing
toilet safes [ __ ] doing way more than
i thought you were doing which is
amazing but
i've known you for a long time i've
learned a lot more right now than a lot
of our conversations about the stuff
you've done yeah it's very uh
inspiring slash eye opening
i didn't know how much you're actually i
mean you're doing a lot yeah i do i was
trying some of the stuff is fun
you're doing a lot a lot man
and i think
that once again now i know why
[ __ ] are out here suing you
let's bring it back to that these are
out here at [ __ ] vegas and strip
clubs going [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] this well
i get it i get why people it's it's
another uh
bad human quality some of those dudes
hired a pirate i hired um private
investigators to follow me around vegas
they were all thinking i was going to be
into something really [ __ ] weird yeah
and the reports were like that
apparently was like
all that he spoke with this guy then he
went here and spoke with this guy he was
hanging in front of this hotel smoking
with this guy then he went to this place
and he smoked inside and he was like
yeah man sorry man
my life was pretty [ __ ] lame bro
sorry it was just i didn't have fun
though you were just hanging that [ __ ]
out then he passed out on the couch yep
that's me then he passed out on the
couch that not in his hotel room
in someone else's couch
like oh sorry man yeah that's me sorry
gotcha
well
the people that are supporting are
supporting what you do and supporting
the
rock giving that's generation rock
giving because that's what it's about so
right now let's take a question or two
from the fans that
marty i didn't know he did this you
already asked the fan questions and you
have them ready yeah yeah it has to do
with this too
so a bunch of people ask this mainly i'm
sodium chloride and oh my god bcs frenzy
of all your inventions of all the skews
and everything across the board has
there been one that stands out as your
favorite yeah yeah definitely it would
be a raw classic one and a quarter
because that was the first one and like
when i think of raw that's the mental
picture i get in my head is that one
pack the wrong posters yeah yeah my
favorite one yeah that was the 3d
rendering on the posters every smoke
shot man every [ __ ] smoke show had it
yeah oh
thinking of raw posters just brings me
back to like
just legally
going into smoke shops just seeing
posters like wrong okay wait wait wait
wait i cloned philly see the feeling you
got there you see that feeling that's
the feeling i had when i was like 15
walking into these [ __ ] little head
shops where i dreamed i wanted to open
my own store that same feeling thomas
and i still get it to this day when i
walk into them but that's the feeling
that's the way i like to feel i know
you're like it's awesome it's like a
world of possibility every time i make
[ __ ] i go
we made that yeah when i was a kid i
would never thought we'd be making this
[ __ ] upstairs
because i used to buy stuff on
drj.com and buy a new shirt coming out
like yeah who designed this shirt what a
cool design i would like to make a shirt
one day 10 years goes by i'm like oh
[ __ ] we're making clothes
that feeling like i remember this and
it's just fun for you it's like going
back into the head shops it's the same
thing it's just
a different perspective same feeling you
wonder what the feeling is it's the
feeling that charlie had when he walked
into the chocolate factory let's go look
at him look at me we talked about some
of this earlier
we talked about this for you guys did
you that's cause it's true you know it's
true it's the feeling man you got that
feeling i get that feeling too it's such
a beauty it's like amazement and
wonderment the world of possibilities
that's what it is yeah it's like there
was anything possible now it's like when
you get i mean i don't have kids
obviously but i have multiple kids slash
businesses that i call my kids and i'm
doing this and doing that and i'm
thinking there's no time for this
there's no time for that and when you
stop and think about it you almost have
no time to stop and think about like
look what we've done
yeah i i know you rarely do that i know
you don't yeah not as much not as my
[ __ ] at all you know like almost never
get i know you there's got to be a time
where you're the only one in the
warehouse on a skateboard and just
that's when it happens yep that'd be the
only time we just hear wheels only i'm
there on a saturday for some reason it
happens to be one where no one else is
working and i'm skateboarding around the
place like having trying to allow myself
to accept the wowness like oh my god
this is real this is [ __ ] real this
is [ __ ] real this is [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] real you know just you have to
be by yourself yeah you have to keep it
right i didn't think about that you have
to that's the only time you can remember
oh wow in fourth grade i did this
because other people it's not a
distraction it's you have to give your
energy to somebody else to go
hey i'm you're cool right everything's
good you're not bored not sitting there
me just [ __ ] space now
and when you're by yourself you allow
yourself to be kind of selfish
with your time okay that's how i look at
it when there's other people i can't
i have to be like you good everything
good in my head because it's always
i think of how are you feeling kind of
thing when you just by yourself when's
the last time you'd laid down next to a
tree and just laid there by yourself
it's been a while i've done it but it's
been a while it's been too [ __ ] long
now that you said it
a child this last time i ever did it
yeah
that feeling right there is the feeling
going through the thing like
wow we did this [ __ ] oh my god it's real
and you especially if your [ __ ]
warehouse is a costco yeah
it's huge dude it it's [ __ ] massive
that the right when they're in the shelf
when it came in when i got to go it's
kind of like josh's shelf it's the first
thing i thought when the landlord left i
mean it's like kind of like the raw
shelves
wow like phone those are forklifts in
here but
good [ __ ] yeah so when i was here the
first night i had a bong i was hitting
it with
we have a [ __ ]
and you cannot barely accept it right
mm-hmm yeah
not even yet every time you walk through
my oh my god the office
won't even work locking up like oh my
[ __ ] god because you know i was in my
apartment forever yeah so you don't
allow yourself to have that because it's
the rare moment that you're by yourself
in there i'm gonna do it more now yeah
you have to man just ride there
smoke and just listen to the skateboard
wheels it's gonna echo and you're gonna
be by yourself
it's just
that's what it's about it's so fun
i know you especially because you have
that gigantic spot so that's what i'm
trying to say
you don't have to you don't allow
yourself to get that way but you have to
so now you said that i wouldn't want it
in my mind it's not gonna stop
there you go yeah what how old is raw
right now how long have you been doing
raw the actual brand
i like
right around 2004 until now you're
looking at 18 years right wow yeah how
many people does it take to make a
company like rahrana a lot
because like um it depends upon what you
mean by company and people like for
example in bali just making cones there
are thousands
so you've got that going on where
there's that many thousands
and then you've got um
an alkoy a couple hundred and uh in
arizona 100 or so direct then you have
all like um
we have so many things it's like
uh like this grinder over here that um
the hemp plastic grinder this is
assembled by special needs workers and
workers really special needs
in phoenix arizona so
and we try to keep them full or they're
working non-stop on our projects so is
that is that an employee that
non-employee
the impact's much bigger than there's
germany there's ireland
there's um
oh man canada
there's it just goes on and on and so
many things that are working for people
that are working for you directly or
indirectly where you're just like you
have to kind of realize like oh my gosh
there's really really a lot of people
like a lot of people that's only on the
raw part and then you have all like the
cyclones and all the other things that
are made in the philippines the zen you
make [ __ ] cyclones yeah yeah of
course stop it you're talking about the
big cyclone the cyclones not the not the
vaporizer there's no no the cyclone
the cone yeah yeah those are all me
that's what i said when i walked i see
the i should see the cyclones yeah wrong
i didn't know you made cycles man yeah
me and my friends it was 4 20 i was 18
years old we all go you think we can
fill one of these up
you know how much we to fill that [ __ ]
up and we bought it
yeah a big one we filled it in that
square box it was like the total
box
you made that [ __ ] my 18th birthday
thank you very much that's my 18th 420.
yeah that's what the [ __ ] i did it's
kind of cycling with ryan and everybody
that's awesome wow that's the biggest
tip in the world
for the [ __ ] world it had to be it
had to be because the weight the sheer
weight yeah yeah wow
josh you've been there since i've been a
kid yeah man i'm doing this for a while
oh god i love it
i didn't know that so it's essentially
hundreds of workers about 18 years
building yeah yeah well thousands really
thousands of people around the world
it's just oh yeah thousands really
anyone who's involved in it you're
really part of the family in a way one
way or another and so you're and then oh
god then it goes on and on to all the
people you know that work with it and
dictate other pack with booklet makers
everybody so yeah it's gonna be
thousands for sure
and they um
yeah and they're all so you have that
kind of responsibility now here's a cool
here's something i came to understand
if let's say you
it's like a it's good and bad
when it's when it's your factory when
you're the one who's really it's all on
you man and you feel it and you're
visiting them and you're spending time
with these people and you connect with
the people again it's more weight and
responsibility if you're just buying it
like like um
you know if we were just buying this
glass tube from a glass tube factory we
don't think about all the people that
work in it we don't think about any of
that stuff and you don't have that you
don't end up with the weight
responsibility it's the glass too you
buy it you work on you get the quality
right price right and you're out
if you're making the glass tubes
it adds a whole another level on to you
where it's like
and again more weight more
responsibility which you can hopefully
turn into a good thing of more like no
we must succeed we must sell more glass
tubes because i got all of them and
their families to support oh we want to
make we want to hire even more their
cousins and more other people we got to
do it more
this is something i picked up from my
grandfather like i didn't want to be
involved in manufacturing and going to
the level with all these products i'd
it's much easier to just buy it from
someone and sell it it feels so much
cleaner but you know you don't you don't
get it deep in there and you don't have
that that weight weight you don't have
the weight
but grandpa taught me and he raised me
josh you've got to make it with your you
got to make it yourself he would say
with your own two hands i don't make
them with my own two hands but he the
feeling is that he wants me involved he
had a sweater factory and he insisted he
he insisted on making he wouldn't trade
he would only make his own sweaters and
sell them he wouldn't use other
factories he would only make his own
sweaters and stuff oh yeah he wanted to
be involved he wanted to have control of
it he wanted it has my name on there i
want to know it's right and he insisted
on doing things in that way and he
implanted that into me so that even on
things that i don't make myself i have
to [ __ ] with it quality control we have
a hard time we have a whole quality
control department but when it comes in
after they're done with it it still
comes to me and i still got to [ __ ] with
it and sit there and play with it is
that really right is that really right
is it right as right can be there's
something better i should have been done
hey the color looks off on that sticker
is that sticker peeling off easy enough
that sticker i'll tell you honestly this
product is i'm angry about this product
because this sticker right here is
supposed to come off easier than it does
it's leaving a little bit of residue
behind and i know that's going to annoy
you you see you see it's going to annoy
you isn't it and i knew it was going to
annoy you and i specified a certain type
of sticker it was supposed to be a
certain way and it came in without the
right sticker on your perfectionist
because not a perfectionist i'm doing
this it's doing it for me and for you
the same way that sticker peel a noise
everyone would go to this thing
everyone's getting annoyed by the
sticker peel on every product ever
bought it annoys me too
i use this [ __ ] man i want to take that
sticker off and put in my pocket easy
i have a responsibility to you and to
everybody to make it as good as it can
be and if a sticker peel off leave some
freaking residue that i [ __ ] up but i
didn't do my job right
and i can't that's what i mean yeah if
you know it's not gonna be perfect and
you know somebody can
if you know there can be a complaint why
[ __ ] do it that way yeah
that's how i see everything i just saw i
look at that as being a perfectionist
for everyone's
for consumer when i make something or
think of something yeah i go
would i want to buy this if it wasn't me
and that's how i look at everything like
[ __ ] yeah i wish it's hard damn man
that's great that's a great way to look
at it yeah but
yeah i would you know i mean to look
around like yeah every single thing here
is needed [ __ ]
and you start thinking like just for
smoking yeah this is the most fun part
is all the stuff that you could [ __ ]
with outside yes
you know yes like cool cool glass cool
yeah use a gatorade bottle like no this
really cool thing has a slide it has
this work piece it's got a double bubble
double chamber man infiltration with an
ice bath bro it's like uh it's like
growing up and going no my squirt gun my
my nerf gun is way tighter than your
nerves
yeah it's not like a competition thing
it's more like oh wow i love his i gotta
get a cool one new one it's an
appreciation
all this color mine
you know yeah yeah yeah how many people
are saying that right now where can i
get that tray yeah exactly because it's
[ __ ] awesome
and it's it's never changing it's fun
you buy new shoes because it's like oh i
had those shoes it was a different color
i like those yeah one's a new tray it's
a cool cool design wow why do you need
that you don't but i [ __ ] want it i
love what you said in the beginning of
that i really do i love how you
did someone would someone buy this if
they weren't me like that mindset of
like is this actually needed by them is
this cool enough you know would they
would is it cool but i think what you're
doing is the same thing i do it's like
you're putting yourself back into that
early state when you walked into that
first smoke shop right and it's like and
there's your product you're imagining it
on the shelf
would i have to buy that thing would i
be like holy [ __ ] would i be would i be
giving that feeling and the answer is
yes then [ __ ] yeah we got to do we got
to do we got to do we got to do we got
it i don't care what the [ __ ] it is man
we got to do it i got to make a holder
that comes around and holds the cone
like this with a little catcher on the
bottom because that's [ __ ] ridiculous
i know that if i walked into that store
and saw that my mind would be [ __ ]
gone
you see greek comments you see like i
was at a smoke shop and i said i wish i
had this and look what the [ __ ] i found
get those dms like
that's what it was for that's awesome
yep that's what that's why you made this
stuff that's why you made the ring
because how many people go i only wear
these because it's [ __ ] awesome and
i'm at parties and people like what yes
where did you get that [ __ ] yeah it's
just fun i've never seen a smokeable
ring where you can smoke through your
damn ring and it's hygienic
you're really thinking about everything
you do man it's very cool to see and i
hope everyone in here can see it
everything had a story okay on to the
next fan question that you got who's up
who's up marty okay
let's see here we got
coming in hot now this is the dope as
usual podcast instagram we never [ __ ]
mention this go follow that [ __ ]
never mention that huh yeah we've
literally never met never mentioned
[Laughter]
we're good at marketing for other people
but never for ourselves well it's time
to do it no no no we need to but yeah
that's our instagram and that's where
you asked this question yeah what was
the instagram again
dope as usual podcast at dopa's usual
podcast yeah we never said that one time
so we got uh at asadh09
what makes your sense of style so unique
compared to anyone else who's turned
their business into a social media
platform
huh that's a really good question
um i really i guess
[Music]
imagine being the person you kind of
wish you always had been so like you
know i grew up think picturing these
real [ __ ] badass rock and rollers you
know robert plant you'd see [ __ ]
david lee ross jumping up there doing
splits and a pair of [ __ ] leopard
leotards wearing this crazy [ __ ]
scarf and [ __ ] seeing these [ __ ]
rockers doing their thing man david
bowie and [ __ ] and just the dream was
like looking at them think look at the
level of freedom they had they could
wear whatever the [ __ ] they wanted
whenever they wanted they could just do
whatever they wanted
they were cool no matter what the [ __ ]
you wear you made that [ __ ] type yes
yeah you're right so then it was just
kind of like it just kind of finds its
way into your style you go further and
further into that direction until next
time you know you're just [ __ ]
leveling it and you're making you learn
hey how did david lee roth get his
scarves to flow like that and you learn
it's this [ __ ] rectangular cut if
there's a scarf behind me i'll kind of
show you it's a rectangular cut so
instead of doing a square cut like or
more just a regular cut like some scars
will do you find it you cut it off did
you really cut it like that because of
this reason yes because of this reason
yeah yeah so you cut the scarf man's
attention to details it's off the chain
man and you can make it float
oh my god
you really yeah there's a square tail
right you're trying to get it to get
this crooked and these snaps on the side
you know and it's so yeah it's all about
[ __ ] like that but you're just trying to
you're just
i'm just having fun
best thing you could have said yeah
there's a trailer
because truly you see it though
[Laughter]
yeah i'm just having fun i made 85
[ __ ] things and the story behind it
it makes me more stoked knowing that oh
no let me ask you what do you want two
weeks i'll have it what's your favorite
that's what you said
now you're reading comments going what
was that you like that okay gotcha
it's the same thing except virtually i
read my comments all the time
i'm looking for something i'm trying to
look for someone who says me dude my
tray exploded like it is click dm tell
me what happens what happens tell me
every detail you got pictures of it i
need to see that you're not lying to me
are you you're not [ __ ] with me show me
what happened and then it's like if it's
real which most of the time it isn't
upgrade but yeah of course hit me up let
me see a picture oh my god how did that
happen tell me truth i'm sending you a
new tray anyway tell me how it happened
did you drop it come on tell me the
truth man tell me every little detail i
swear i'm sending you a tray anyway just
tell me what happened and you just get
the information then the next thing you
know i'm on the phone screaming at
people with no necessarily negative way
we let this guy down man what do you
mean the magnet popped off the magnet
popped off the magnet popped off man do
you understand this guy wanted this he
saved up for this and the [ __ ] magnet
popped off do you know what you did to
him you know guys are like josh
yes you have to think that way dude you
ruined his [ __ ] knife
to do one [ __ ] job
one [ __ ] job make that thing right
make him [ __ ] happy and you made him
unhappy
like they're like oh i'm sorry josh
will you really know it isn't about josh
it's about that dude you just [ __ ]
over what i'm saying how do you think
that guy feels like oh i got the dud
yeah i waited for how long and i got the
[ __ ] one [ __ ] no
no no that's what i think about shirts
like oh that's a defect no nope
it's small put it to the side yeah
because you don't want to be that one
guy that waited do you remember being
like just waiting for whatever in the
mail you're getting like are you [ __ ]
kidding me two more weeks i have to send
this back and it's oh my god
no i'm sorry do people know that you
used to sit there and pluck out the
hairs on oh every hat is the threads i
used to get tweezers me and rosie would
take eight or nine hours every time we
got hats we tweezer every [ __ ]
piece every [ __ ]
one piled this big i know it's not a lot
but after like eight hours of little
baby hair strings that's a big pile yeah
it is and me and rosie would every time
just go wow eight hours for this
but i never had to complain about it i
wish you would have saved those oh that
would be kind of cool huh
that's like the whole pile of them
that's a good idea i never thought about
stuff like that we didn't talk about
that
like get it out know what more [ __ ] more
stuff but i finally got an employee dude
i haven't packed an order into over two
weeks good for you it's so weird that's
[ __ ] awesome it's so [ __ ] weird
because i'm a perfectionist oh you got
it down perfect not one messed up order
yet
oh my god this is gonna be mistakes yeah
for sure we know it but it's great
as long as it's been to you know what
you're doing yes it's amazing yeah but
you have this you're doing the same
thing i'm doing when you're sitting
there plucking out strings
yeah yeah we're in the same we're doing
the same thing it's about pride in your
product yeah i'm making people happy and
you can't make them happy if you just if
you give them crap mm-hmm if you if you
[ __ ] up
i mean i i said all the time i'd rather
lose money than you get pissed yes or
feel like because they're gonna
you didn't make this paper you didn't
pack this cone you think you were in the
factory no you weren't but when they go
this thing's [ __ ] up [ __ ] josh
[ __ ] josh i knew that [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] look how look at his hair yeah
look at him let's do his life
so i hope this is the psa for everyone
out there that you can't be perfect
because other people unless it's you
unless you want it back because you'll
do it perfect yeah i will but there's
thank you
that's why i'm so meticulous with
packing [ __ ] because i don't know ups at
workers don't give a [ __ ] they're gonna
throw this thing can i throw it if i
could throw it it doesn't break we could
ship it yeah that's how i feel because
you have to you can't be the kid at home
going what the [ __ ] i got the shitty
shirt
it's not
it's the it's the world's worst thing
and then they think of your image in
your face and you want them to be happy
yes trying to make people happy
oh [ __ ] josh
when you first started raw were you
already so savvy in business that you
came into it with a team or was it just
you doing it until you scaled up into a
team by that point i already had a team
because of elements and juice games
because of elements of jcj's it's a i
look to look at it as a ladder which is
a key piece for anyone if you look at
where i am now
and where i began if you and if you're
here looking at me over here it looks
impossible it just looks impossible man
look at that oh i'll never get there
yeah because i wasn't here though it's
just a [ __ ] ladder you take one one
rung one step at a time it was you know
trading papers wholesaling other
people's papers doing any little thing
you can build that's another step
another step let's customize it will you
let me customize i met a guy who was
taking was making custom packs in okoye
can you make me this can you make me
that yes cool we got that's another step
and another one and another one and
another one and sometimes you fall down
the ladder and that's okay you get back
on you go up again this is what we do
until eventually you end up at the top
of the [ __ ] ladder and i got a better
answer for you which is something i need
something i really need to talk about
for one moment i learned too much of my
life through rolling paper art i really
have right there's a i've got books on
rolling paper art this is something we
do in el coiu maybe it's just not normal
but it we still something we do there's
one pack of papers that has resonated
with me for too long it's called los
angeles and it's a ha the artwork on the
pack imagine this it shows the life of a
person
they start off so zero it shows a little
baby and it's a man a picture of a man
and he's growing up getting older and
older and older 10 20 and it shows as if
as if it's like a chart
and at very at right there when he's at
50 he's at the very top of his life and
then from there it's just down down down
until he goes right back into like an
infantile type state
and you see that and this is implanted
in my brain as this is it josh
so now i'm at the [ __ ] right there at
the very top crescent part right there
and it's all downhill from here so what
do you got to do well nothing i can do
other than go down i'm not going to go
down a pile of flames like certain other
people might have
some people don't like oh actually i
won't mention anything negative um
your job is to
propagate the knowledge you gained on
the way up so that it makes it easier
for the people behind you to come up as
well
and hopefully you can propagate it in
such a way that it adds on some levels
that you really want people to do like i
always tell people i'm going to help you
and then you're going to [ __ ] become
a huge success and when you do
you're gonna give back for real much
more than i ever gave you're gonna next
level my [ __ ] to the [ __ ] you're
gonna make fun of me you're gonna call
me a piece of poop for not giving back
enough at all you're gonna [ __ ] bring
that [ __ ] up there man they're like okay
and that's kind of the part of the deal
i make with people when i'm really going
to give them advice like strong advice
and help them out like all right man
you know you just gotta you gotta level
me up to the [ __ ] laugh at me as you
as you step on my [ __ ] on my tomb of
my stepping stones behind me just laugh
at me dude because i knew nothing
compared to you you are smarter you got
more talent you got more skills you're
going to [ __ ] house me man i got no
chance against you
here's some information what else do you
need how else can i help you how can i
help you elevate learn from my [ __ ]
mistakes you don't got to make them too
man
it makes it easier to get up if you
learn from mine then if you have to
learn yourself that same mistake that i
made [ __ ]
i want to teach people as much as
possible to bring them with me
the goal is of course the real goal
would be
so that in the end
you got more friends you know what i
mean yeah you got more people up there
with you hanging out and having [ __ ]
fun telling stories shooting [ __ ] like
we're doing now you know
i remember when i got you a car alarm
viper viper alarm this tree's a house
because i saw this beautiful monte carlo
you had and i was like me that was like
[ __ ] no like that car's a connor man
three days later i'm like what the [ __ ]
is this in the mail people sent me a
[ __ ] sick-ass car alarm i had my
cousin installing everything i remember
she's loud i was scared max my friends
used to boost cars and i was like oh
[ __ ] they would have been all over that
car oh my god they would've been on it
they've been following you home they
would've been trying to find some way to
get your car like no no no no i gotta
get you an alarm i don't want you losing
that car it's heartbreaking to lose a
car i remember i i'll never forget that
[ __ ] i remember what i remember opening
it going viper
josh this is the [ __ ] alarm you said
you were going to send you really said
the [ __ ] yeah they don't watch your
lizard monty i remember that i remember
my cousin installed like
because who said this josh josh ruined
the paper
i like him for my because he's a car
he's i like that that's very [ __ ]
awesome that he did that one yeah right
i i don't because i don't know about car
i mean he's like this will get stolen in
five [ __ ] seconds like all right all
right thanks but that was just one
little thing and one other thing you
said to me
i was
on my apartment on the davinci first
year i moved there i was in my bed when
it was against the wall
i'm just saying this for my brain
and then you were telling me like
because there was a time
where i would
i mean we all are young or not even
young maybe you're older and you learn
but there was a time where i was like
now [ __ ] that [ __ ] make it better or no
that's not how i want it to work this is
not how you like yo you have to calm
down breathe sometime like josh
i know how to handle my life fool but
you're like no no thomas this is one of
my god i'm like oh my god josh what are
you gonna tell me
and you're like sometimes when i wake up
i feel better when i go
start from your toes
work your way up to your head are you
appreciative of your feet and how they
can help you in the day are you
appreciative and then i get out of bed
and say thank you for every part of my
body that works
and you know then you feel a lot more
relieved and grateful and i'm like
all right josh
and then i did the [ __ ] one day yeah
i love that [ __ ] josh
[Laughter]
josh knows everything i don't though no
i'm saying the things that i am lacking
like i saw that and i see it and i know
how i can help that's how i like don't
[ __ ] stop being so [ __ ] negative you
didn't do that you're like hey try this
yeah i remember where i was sitting when
i'm like what
because it worked for me man that's why
it's like wow i [ __ ] love this this
weird [ __ ] i pick up along the way and i
just want to propagate it i want to
teach everyone all the stuff i picked up
along the way
to make it easier for them plus i got to
tell you a very selfish benefit for me
if i can teach people all this stuff i
learned along the way every little trick
every little [ __ ] thing then in a way
i get to live forever
i was like you live on forever this tech
josh tech that's going to be around for
200 [ __ ] years that's all we got man
if that that thing of sharing knowledge
i'll be gone there's no doubt but the
knowledge lives on
and that's beautiful that's all i can
ask for it's like being a writer
like your [ __ ] lives forever a
storyteller lives forever
in some way shape or form shakespeare's
[ __ ] still gets made
today yeah yeah you know what i'm saying
you knew the story of the
the rolling paper beef
from the 15 1600s
the real beef began would have been
about eighteen eighteen eighteen the
beef the real beef began in the 1800s it
would have started earlier than that but
the real beef would have begun when you
get to the 1800s especially during
industrialization like the coming of um
modern machinery and stuff it got worse
and worse but there's the first
trademarks ever filed in spain i believe
it was the first five of them ever filed
in spain were for rolling papers because
people were competing with each other so
much really they're all stealing each
other's brands so the first thing with
[ __ ] rolling pins is there a reason
why spain seems to be the homeland for
this yes why is it the trees no
it's um
[Music]
i'm gonna do the short version we'll be
here all night man the short version is
and this is part of this is folklore and
completely wrong
the chinese invented paper
arab traitors actually i don't know if
there were traders at the time but there
was a battle between a group of arabs
and chinese we're going back
you know
i don't know more than a thousand years
probably i don't even i'm not even sure
of the top of my head i have it all
written down somewhere
so this battle happens the chinese lose
and are captured by the arabs the arabs
make a deal the chinese make a deal with
them will teach you how to make paper if
you let us go
good smart [ __ ] right really
smart move they teach them and they
teach them how to make paper now this
comes back to the to the arab world
which was
um i think it would have been the
center of civilization at the time
and the whole process of paper making
begins and really takes root and becomes
more perfected when the moors came and
conquered part of spain they brought
with them paper
and they set up the world's first
european paper mill in yativa spain
which is right outside of alcoy and it
didn't operate right because there was
too much rain back then there's no
electricity
you're relying on the sun and the wind
to dry your paper and you need running
water to power the turns like the tire
styles you're going to be moving in
order to make the paper and the baton
which is this big hammer that comes up
and comes down bam mashes bam mashes you
got to mash that stuff you know to make
paper you're taking plants one way or
another and you're mashing the [ __ ] out
of them to smash them down into
cellulose what i call cellulose and
fiber it's all really cellulose what i
call cellulose and fiber because there's
no there's differentiations between it
and now you take that and you're gonna
you spread it out one way or another on
a screen
get it into the sun and wind in order to
get it dry take it off the screen and
you have essentially your paper that's
essentially it right this is the old old
old way all right now that's happening
they bring it from yativa to alcoy and
set up the real world's first european
paper bill operational operating well in
alcoy and this becomes the paper-making
capital of all of europe and really the
paper-making capital what year or what
century is this oh okay now we're going
back to
[Music]
about the
it would have been you know 1500 1600s
right around there what a lot of this is
happening
when the paper mills are really getting
going you're going back yeah they got
better and better in 1600s 1700s they
continually got better and improved and
improved the the the um
the akoyanos rose up to this to the
sign of saint george and chased the
moors out this is the story and they
still have a party about it to this day
it's a party of peace and celebration
it's really cool and um
it's called the mordos a christianos
festival
i
actually have to protest at the festival
they do things i don't like there as
well so i go there sometimes no there's
things i don't like nothing negative and
i'm trying to change their ways and
they're listening to me and it's going
to work out
um
[Music]
so this is paper making is part of the
history of el coy you can't study paper
without passing through alcoy you can't
study rolling paper or anything without
passing through alcoa so spain really is
the history of rolling paper
it's amazing yeah
what a [ __ ] history lesson right now
of something i actually like yeah now
imagine this imagine how you're gonna
feel like this picture this as i go
around through alcoy you're going around
and on the right down by the river
because it's all mountains and ravines
you look down by the ravines eventually
you look far enough if you follow the
river all you're seeing are old paper
mills
i mean old
paper mills you know oh and then i'll be
with one of the um historians and he'll
explain to me oh yes this one is from
1742 and you're like okay that's older
than america he's like yeah so
okay all right come show it to me we see
what's left of it you find some
derelicts and you'll find something in
the dirt and then eventually we'll take
a little um a little rock from one of
the foundations not from it it's held on
the ground you don't take it off you
pick it up and we bring it to the new
factory plant it in the four corners of
the factory different rubble you pick up
from the older ones just to connect the
present to the past and to pay homage to
the ancestors now all this i'm telling
to you is because imagine if as you
walked in here to do this podcast you
were literally walking on
the graves of the people who had done
podcasts before you hundreds of years
ago and then you finally stepped into
the room to go do your podcast you get a
different feeling man it's like i get
that like
but you also realize you recognize
the briefness and the lightness of it
all that you are just one link in that
chain man and all you can do is be the
best link you can be there were all
those pieces before you and you know
damn well someone else could be walking
on your [ __ ] laughing at your rubble
picking up pieces from your factory and
planting it into their own in the future
and you just look at it like that and it
changes the way you feel about so many
things wow and gives you perspective i
love that yeah
so yeah
that was [ __ ] awesome i'm just
thinking of like yep that's exactly how
life works it's such a brief moment
they're actually here yeah so now based
on that and based on everything i
[ __ ] rambled about and sorry for
rambling too long now but i do yeah and
i'm holding back on smoking as you
imagine if you let me go it's gonna keep
going
it's um
if you were gonna give a message
to your let's go back let's go really
back to your 10 year old self
right and you could you see him there
there's little thomas and he's right
there and you know all this information
you have now
what's the first thing you're going to
say to 10 year old thomas
i've been asked this something like this
before it's the same answer it's like
it's gonna be okay it'll get better
it's all i ever think like yo
it sucks dick right now but just wait
that's how i always i grew up everything
until i was of able to take care of
myself when were you able to take care
of yourself
16 okay so now you got 18 year old
thomas you got to give him a different
message there he is and he's starting to
try to make a hustle and trying to make
himself
get forward keep it going keep going
that's it there's no advice i would give
to my 18 year old self because that
[ __ ] was smart as [ __ ] and
brought it up to where we're at
and from 18 and on it's just been the
same [ __ ] thing non-stop except you
know i stopped selling certain things
that's it and it started going in
another direction i'm into this i met
you guys
a year into this you know
a decade this november that i've been
doing this which is insane for me to
even think it's been a decade it's been
a [ __ ] decade yeah
that's great
it's weird but the 18 year old thing
just
i don't think i give any different
advice because i [ __ ] loved it and
all the way up
i wouldn't change anything if i can give
advice to my 28 year old self yeah
that's a whole difference what is it
mine is like yo shut the [ __ ] up start
working a lot harder
quadruple what you're doing stop hanging
out and just work as much as you
possibly can because i waited until i
was like 30 to really like i'm gonna
film every single day i'm gonna edit
every day all day every single thing
everything i don't care about hanging
out
and that's when everything is that's
only because you
realize you enjoyed it better doing this
than that i realized i was gonna just
plateau forever
and never continue
with
making better content doing something
better if i was just like yo let's hang
out all day i'll get my stuff done
tomorrow no it's like yeah i'll see you
guys this weekend i'm gonna do like 25
hours of editing and filming today
because i don't care i know it's more
than a day obviously but all day every
day i don't care what we're doing
it was when the pandemic happened and i
realized like
i got to start actually making money so
i can help people out when stuff gets
bad yeah because it got bad and i went
thank god i'm actually making money
finally yeah because before that i would
have been what am i going to do
it's over
move back
so that's really what made me think
because i always did everything for free
man i did because i love it it's so fun
but it's more of i have to start
establishing things and start doing
things for myself that could help me
help the former me in five years go hey
don't worry all that [ __ ] here's a
camera i got you help me do some stuff
i'll pay you rent that's the thing like
the the you know i mean there's always
going to be the younger version of you
coming out and you see it and go i can
help you because i know where you're at
and it [ __ ] sucks where you're at if
i had someone going here's ten thousand
dollars start your business
oh my [ __ ] god
that would have been crazy like i wanna
get to the point where i can see it spot
and just be fine to go here
what can you do go for it
you know i understand but you're missing
a piece there what because like from the
place you're talking about i know where
you're talking from and i feel what
you're what you're feeling but i believe
that
a lot of it is because you recognize how
much you actually enjoy doing this
because i know you and i know you like
sitting here right now and i know you
love this so i think what a lot of what
you're saying also that you need to
clarify because people don't understand
because the message isn't just to work
harder the message is hey man
recognize if you like doing something
what you like doing go the [ __ ] into it
full bar don't you [ __ ] stop you
[ __ ] dedicate 25 hours a [ __ ] day
to it because you love it and it's gonna
be gone at a [ __ ] moment and yeah you
can make money off if you do all these
things but if you're if you're
half-hearting and doing it if you're
[ __ ] around with your friends too
much and not giving enough to that
passion of yours your passion
that's what it was
you're wasting your gift
yes that's why i was yeah i was sitting
realizing i didn't do anything
productive today
and it's not pretty it's like oh you're
making weed videos and no it's not i'm
waking me videos it's there's businesses
behind this i don't get
any revenue
i have to find a way to do this so i can
continue to do what i [ __ ] love doing
yeah
and that's how it's funneling and
helping like you're saying how are you
doing story time i know i'm paying for
it because i [ __ ] love it even though
i'm not getting paid in the back end
there's no there's nothing coming from
her i'm not getting youtube i [ __ ]
love it so he's paying for all this
himself just you know we had a
conversation off camera he's paying for
all this himself he's doing something
tomorrow that is i won't spoil it anyway
yeah it's [ __ ] amazing and he paid
for it all himself yeah because it's
gonna be that much [ __ ] doper when
people watch and go oh my god is the
passion you have for this thing
you feel that of course i love this [ __ ]
i just want it to be like in five years
ago look how sick we thought that was
look what the [ __ ] we're doing now and
just look back and see little grips
of
upgrades
we're the same man yeah exactly the same
we're doing the same exact thing just
with different products we're going down
different paths taking the same [ __ ]
driving the same car i don't know how to
say it ready better than that man but
that's really it
so yes and there's your advice to people
i think i say it's [ __ ] beautiful
pretty good [ __ ] interviewer josh
you're pretty good
[Laughter]
i loved it that was great this is like
the modern innovator though this really
didn't exist so much before the internet
where you could like oh no i'm really
into weed now i can pave a way to make
an awesome career that's going to then
trickle down to a bunch of other people
through it because i love it
yeah you know they could teach business
classes about that so [ __ ] lucky i
started doing this [ __ ] when i started
yeah
it was the
it was meant to happen because at the
other time i got away with something
else i don't think you did anything
wrong i know i know you're you're
judging on your on your previous self on
your 28 yourself i feel it but i can
tell you from experience if you didn't
spend that time doing that you'd be mad
at yourself for that you would have been
like i never had that experience i never
did that
and you then you'll be [ __ ] 80 years
old thinking with the reason i hang out
enough right i wasted my whole life
working you're going to say something
like that to yourself i experience both
now right so now you experience what you
did it exactly right i didn't you got it
i see what you're saying that would be
my advice is
step up now yeah start now year
it's there's always times you've seen it
we've known each other for a long time
so
you even told me five six years ago you
gotta stop showing weed
you told me that he told me that when i
moved here you gotta you gotta somehow
be the weed guy without showing packs
yeah and be
what i'm doing now is what you told me
to do yeah exactly what i'm doing now i
told you like i gotta be able to be the
weed guy and not have to be the weed guy
right
that's exactly that's the first thing i
said when i met your life yeah that's
what he told me before he moved to l.a
because they [ __ ] hate on us yeah
they performed daily he told me that
like you got you have this
it's not the weed it's you so make sure
it's
it's what people want to get
exactly what i'm trying to transition to
is exactly what you told me so that's
what i'm saying like i said earlier like
yo be grateful just think you've said a
lot of things to me that i've taken and
actually used and that they've worked
so thank you for that i really do and
also when i try to when i did stop
eating meat and [ __ ] you really helped
me out all right yeah helped me out
tremendously because this full how long
have you been vegan 20 something years
oh jesus yeah he showed me his first
person ethiopian food touch with your
hand yeah i even thought
no you don't got a plate
i just remember him well yeah i'm just
eating this
oh god fold it there's a technique but
yeah i know i just to me i'm like oh
medieval it's like going to medieval
times like yeah jousting man [ __ ]
eat with your hands i thought it was
tight you know but that's when i thought
like
yeah josh is on to some other things
he's lived his life and he's looking at
me and going i know where you're at i
know how you're thinking now here's my
advice and you did people did that for
me but thank you because i try to do it
for people that i see too
it's just
why have why why watch someone struggle
when you know what the [ __ ] they need to
hear
they might not take it into
consideration yeah man you told me that
[ __ ] six years ago i still i remember it
yeah brought up specifically because i i
remember and i think about it yeah so
yeah thanks that helps you're welcome to
help it did happen and i did a great
thing which is [ __ ] because if i
helped somebody and i elevated you in
any way that's [ __ ] awesome you know
when i was um younger i get depressed
over [ __ ] my own
my life is a [ __ ] waste blah blah
blah what am i doing all that kind of
[ __ ] you know and not like i was much
younger but it was a while ago nowadays
time is relative right
what i would tell myself once the
rolling papers began moving better and
better i was like hey josh because i was
really always hiding my hat on
hey
you made probably a million people
around the world enjoy their smoke a
little bit more than before
that's an awesome you basically
increased happiness
you did more than anyone else you
actually know isn't that true josh and
i'll be laying there in bed tell myself
huh
yeah i guess that is actually true
yep i guess so yeah that's actually true
you just do things yeah i could have
been an accountant i could have done
which would have had no real impact in
increasing a lot of human beings
happiness right i really could have been
a [ __ ] accountant and
instead i managed to really make a lot
of people happier and yeah the people
the actual direct lives that i'm trying
to save that's amazing too
but the overall impact that i think that
i've had so far and will continue to
have until i'm gone is a very positive
one on
humanity
which is like the real goal because i
think that's what we're supposed to do
100
right you're supposed to leave it better
yeah yeah i think i [ __ ] hate people
litter here's a psa i didn't have to ask
you stop littering and i know you hate
[ __ ] that litter too please
stop littering
stop
that's one thing that i can't stand but
it's like there's one thing that we can
try
how about this
make it okay to go hey you're an [ __ ]
for littering check your i check my
friends all the time like what the [ __ ]
you pick it up what are you doing
i can't stand looking at and that's just
i know it's kind of like it's not a
positive thing but it's more of like
tough love yeah if that's one thing we
could do and this one little message
anybody could do if you litter just
remember me and josh would
not want to be your homeless we wouldn't
want to if we saw you just throw trash
in the [ __ ] ground i wouldn't go look
at you and say thank you exactly it
changes my perspective yeah i'd be like
okay what happened mm-hmm like
okay so that's how you think no it's a
lack of empathy except
somebody somebody else pick it up but
what about that
that could be me on trash patrol for
getting [ __ ] pulled over [ __ ] up or
something because i don't want to be
there picking up your trash come on
like it's um it's
yeah it's a small simple thing but like
you're saying it shows a lack of empathy
because there's a lack of empathy yeah
you're completely right and before we
get on to the next thing
you said the reason why
you have been vegan you are vegan so
long as i'm bringing some of the podcast
he says it's it's
empathy
yeah people always ask like yo why would
why how and why because you remember
when i was eating [ __ ] you were never
like hey you know you're [ __ ] up
right it was never that you never once
said that [ __ ] to me it doesn't work
yeah when i'm not gonna change you over
it's not it has to be you yeah yeah i
told maureen i've told it i was driving
on the uh on the grapevine and i saw all
these cows the sun was out it was
overcast with the sun came out and i saw
and go how the [ __ ] can i eat these
[ __ ] things yeah they're just
beautiful so cool
what am i doing yeah and then i ate meat
and everything that night and got food
poisoning first time in my life
and i went there's my sign
i said i was gonna stop how could i do
it i ate it that night never again
and that was six seven years yelling at
you for sure exactly i've never had food
poisoning before i was sick
throwing up for three days no the
universe was telling you no more there
you go that's your fault and i thought
like nope i can't ever do it again and
then
and i talked to you
geez man the dairy you gotta stop you
gotta and then i looked into it a little
more
and you've helped me a lot actually man
just by having random phone calls i was
talking about random things
so yes that's another thing but that's
same thing for you
it was too much is that for you too it
was cows yeah my motorcycle broke down
next to a cow cow pasture there was a
tree that overhang the road and the cows
like the cows on one side the fence is
right up against the tree and i'm on the
other side i'm there for hours till my
friend came with a part to get my old
bike i built myself going again and
i'm just hanging out with the cows all
day connecting with them and one mama
cow i'm making cow jokes at them i had
nothing else to do right so and one of
them
bumped at one another one and i started
going move over right and the cow like
turns to me and turns and walks away and
goes over the little hill and i was like
it's something i said sorry honey you
know she's gone she comes back a moment
later with her baby and she pushes her
baby up to the fence to say hi to me
so i'm petting the cow and i'm really
looking at their eyes you know
and you're looking right at them they're
looking right at you and i'm seeing
a nose
two eyes
ears
mouth i'm like oh these guys are exactly
the same as me aren't they like oh gosh
[ __ ] i'm like this is really us isn't it
this is a real living thing just like me
okay get the connection get the whole
thing get my bike going again make my
way up to tallahassee florida i go down
and i order myself a cheeseburger and i
take one bite into that cheeseburger and
it happened to be cooked extra rare
and the blood comes running out of it
right same thing thomas same thing man
because the universe sends signals and
it sent you and me the same ones and the
blood runs out onto the [ __ ] plate
and i looked down at there and i was
like
oh [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
picturing the baby cow and the mama cow
and how much i really just betrayed her
and the whole thing i'm just like
i was [ __ ] i was just [ __ ] [ __ ] i
didn't finish the burger
i got that message right and i was just
like i can't i can't i can't i can't
okay and then later on if i ever even
thought about it i would go into like
the bodies going into the convulsions
like i can't i can't i can't no no he's
like oh sorry cow i don't love you
anymore i'm sorry it's okay i'm just
gonna eat you no man no no no no [ __ ]
that and i got more and more stories
just like that one animal at a time till
eventually i was just done
and you can't go back
all those years at earth save that i was
on the board of earth save into canada i
learned two things one you can't convert
someone if they're not already vegan you
can say whatever you want to them but
they can only do it to themselves you
can share the information and when
someone is ready to receive that
information they will receive it
until then you're just [ __ ] hopeless
and the other thing i learned was
the people that became vegan based on
the study we funded the people that
became vegan that stayed vegan the most
were the ones who based on the survey
that i worked on their final answer for
why they were vegan was
love it with love and empathy the ones
who are i look at that cow and i love
that cow i see the cow i see the cree
the life inside i know that it's got
feelings i know it's got emotions i know
it really feels pain and it's scared
beyond as much as i would be scared when
it's about to die and it's watching his
kids get taken away from and all that
stuff it really feels it and once you've
got that you're like oh [ __ ] yep what do
i do now man give me some [ __ ]
soybeans because i'm [ __ ] give me some
black bean burgers
because gotta be better than the paint
i'm gonna feel if i eat that thing so
[ __ ] give me the soybeans i'll be
good i'll be good and then you learn to
enjoy being vegan you learn wow i
actually get to taste more flavors wow
it's actually a good thing i think i
tell my friends like you love steaks
right have you ever just cooked a steak
like no i seasoned it put all my stuff
on you mean the vegetables
gotcha
so what taste bomb is like some salt
yeah and green onion and squash
[ __ ] yeah like that's what in my
head that got up as soon as
that day happened i was done i remember
i looked at it and go i remember the
picture of the cow with the [ __ ] sun
hitting going how could i do that yeah
yeah yeah yeah wow what a wild story man
i can't believe it was almost the same
[ __ ] yeah yeah it was the universe
telling me like don't be an [ __ ] yeah
and then when you didn't quite listen
they got
yelling at you three hours later i did
it again yeah like i was gonna be okay
first time in my life i ate shrimp i
don't like shrimp and i ate i'm like
[ __ ] shrimp and burger and i got sick
as [ __ ] i was a pf chang [ __ ] pf chicks
i got sick as hell um yeah i just wanted
to ask why because
you have told me so much since i've
known you and every time i'm like what
do you mean you're eating paste paste
what kind of paste
i was eating mcdonald's at the stuff i
was still
going hard
i was still at that stage but you never
once like
shamed me for it like every once in a
while never once i won't say that any
good it doesn't help but yeah try it or
don't it's all good it'd be great if it
worked it worked out yeah but doesn't it
doesn't no it's um
at some point everyone feels it i think
that um anyone who isn't vegan is one
thing i've learned later on in life
they're they're gonna wish they were
it's just because life none just you end
up with more health problems you end up
with heart attacks and all that kind of
yeah that too it's just
i mean i don't know why marty stopped
eating me but to me it's like i stopped
to eat meat when i was five cause i saw
the foster farms truck and go why are
there chickens in there i asked my mom's
like they're gonna go get killed i'm
done and eat me for a week i was a kid
my mom's like there's no way there's no
way you're gonna and that's the first
time i ever went
you want to [ __ ] eat this thing i
like and it ruined my brain so from a
kid i remember thinking like i can't do
this yeah
but i still did and then marty i didn't
know you've married for a year and a
half and i'm like do you want this
chicken sandwich though he goes alberto
eat me
like what since when like since lost my
life
okay i'm going to give you one beautiful
point to close this with all right
in the future
it's unrealistic that this isn't true
in the future we will all be vegan and
i'll tell you why
imagine this all right we're going to go
with star trek sorry if you like star
wars i love that too we're going with
star trek you're flying through space at
warp factor [ __ ] nine right you're
fine we're on our way to planet zeta
theta and here we are on our way and you
get hungry
what do you do press a button to someone
down on the meat deck who's gonna kill a
[ __ ] cow and grind you up a burger
that's not happening there's no [ __ ]
way that's happening it's going to be
some kind of synthesized plant protein
the whole spaceship is probably going to
be filled with plants to give us oxygen
that we need as we go and it's all going
to be right there here's your vegan
burger or whatever the hell it is you
actually want and it's going to be also
designed in different ways but it's all
going to be plant-based
it's going to happen that way i think
it's the easiest sustainable way to
there's going to be no animals to eat on
that plane i'm sorry on the plane on the
spaceship there's no [ __ ] way man
yeah the future is vegan we will be
vegan all of us eventually it's just
that's just
natural and it's going to be great it
really is it's going to be great
we're going to be on spaceships eating
[ __ ] we're going to get a spaceship
eating [ __ ] toy burgers it's going to
be amazing maybe six comments guys these
guys got high
that's the top that's the name of this
like
soy burgers is spacious
oh my god um
before we get here i have one thing left
to do sure all right it's called who are
you in the 90s
we have these questions and i'm going to
say one thing and another thing you pick
what you would go with not based on your
now knowledge but based on you in the
90s oh god i know because that's because
he brings you to a different timeline
yeah i thought different back then
back then that's how i feel about myself
so i like to ask this okay all right are
you ready yup all right all right ready
ready ready ready ready ready ready very
basic questions but
you don't have to say why but if you
have a reason why let us know okay vh1
or mtv mtv oh and not even a second
invitation it's an easy one it's back
when the world premieres and music
videos yeah
it was the best man right talk about it
a lot yeah i could just picture that mtv
oh my gosh
at the bottom the lines the record
company such a icon oh so it was so fun
mm-hmm um
okay mtv not even a hesitation here we
go adam sandler or jim carrey
oh sandler man he had more fun i know
carrie's funnier but sandler literally
looked like he was having more fun dude
he got to do those [ __ ] ridiculous
[ __ ] with bob barker come on man there's
no [ __ ] way
and i've seen that too many times
there's one inconsistency how is he
laying on his back grabs and sandler
then the next clip when he gets choked
the arms all the way up
sorry but that's the one cut sometimes
elevation
just sprung up
so strong
little thin microphone
giving space made or neuter questions i
love that movie yes adamson is my
favorite person ever love jim carrey
though yeah great are you ready oh do we
change this
i'm going to change it okay full house
or family matters you were also not a
little child in the 90s so right you
might have not have been i was going
with family members okay here we go yeah
we can just end that one with i've seen
urkel
you weren't you were making pipes yes
you probably weren't watching full house
no i know come on everyone knows urkel
then yeah exactly
forrest gump
pulp fiction
and it's the 90s
pulp fiction man that's so much more fun
and [ __ ] bam bro oh yeah yeah you
know pulp fiction that was fun that's a
lifestyle mm-hmm yeah his favorite movie
you seem to me like somebody that would
love pulp fiction yeah yeah yeah more
than than a
yeah it's good i just recently watched
it again
why was my mom let me do watch that at
five years old crank caller crank caller
crico who's this you know who that guy
is that's rocky dennison oh really for
masks yeah yeah that's him the daryl i
didn't know that same guy holy crazy huh
same dude from mask with cher the guy
with the deformity that's the same dude
i don't know that's a good movie all
right good movie i know you've seen mask
and there's a good movie um mario or
donkey kong
mario man it's gotta be mario it's gotta
be mario gotti mario same it's just too
iconic i don't know iconicky honks fun
but yeah we had one donkey kong person
who was it was adam
he might have played a lot of donkey
kong back when he was in new york it had
been something i don't know but i
remember that wasn't gonna answer that
question so you said 20 something years
vegan this is before and we ask
everybody this
it's for me it's more based on
who what kind of kid you were but you
weren't a kid
mcdonald's or burger king but you didn't
care about that stuff especially if
you're in the well yeah but in the 90s i
would have cared i would have been more
for mcdonald's because for some reason
my my mom hated mcdonald's so we never
get it oh you have a story behind it
yeah yeah then finally there was this
one place down like near us in new york
there was some [ __ ] up mcdonald's that
was so [ __ ] up that they had to take
the ammo m down
it was still mcdonald's but it didn't
have the m on it
yeah it was like mcdonald's it really
was and so i mean we'd go there and
you'd get the mcdonald's but it wasn't
mcdonald's then it became mcdonald's
again but like
what the [ __ ] i don't know man
some mcdowell situation it really was
this really was from coming to america
it was just like that but he ran his
restaurant clean i remember ours lost
its m the story was because they were
like they weren't cleaning up the rats
or something hey man our mcdonald's is
so bad they took our m away
wow i thought merced was [ __ ] bad
just ursad right now yeah i know queens
was a little different yeah oh and it
was in queens also yeah oh my god okay
but it doesn't really it's on the border
of hempstead in queens so it isn't like
the deep and freaking i know where
you're going right now coming to america
i've never been to new york so that's
what i imagine just when you get further
out into queens it's basically like long
island which means it's more spread out
it isn't as as
each other yeah it isn't as urbanized as
as like in coming to america which has
been more likely
and stuff yeah okay closer to the city
gotcha gotcha so my next one ready
michael jordan or michael jackson jordan
dude yeah that was quick jordan hell
yeah man you're saying the whole time
you ever seen him play basketball live
yeah you have well on tv oh it's like in
person no not a person it's just i don't
know i don't think we've met a person
yet or asked the person yet they go i've
seen that full plate no i did not see
you can play live not yet we'll get
we'll get there one day someone's like
yeah on tv though hell yeah i've only
seen one game tv played for the wizards
that's how young i was when he was like
i'm done and i remember we went to play
baseball and it didn't work out oh space
jam i'm with it i was a kid but uh oh i
guess this one we got we got to come up
with the better one
it's always in the 90s for me it's it's
it was always the orange soda or nesquik
were you the we gotta change the sun to
light or nest quick remember the little
rabbit for me it was nest quick oh you
really didn't [ __ ] with [ __ ] this oh
okay
i get a whole [ __ ] top of that for
just a couple bucks no matter how messed
up i could even eat i would eat that
[ __ ] plain powder
you're looking so good always coughed
that's total like smoker candy i'm so
excited that you actually i didn't think
you but this is pretty yeah the metal
please top off at the whole thing of
course
i've been smoking for a long time when i
got older that was my weekend oh he got
older so what it would make everything
taste like nesquik oh no i'd clean it
yeah right my friend my friend rick to
this day barry says weed oh you know
what let me just go with him
no no no no no no no no no
he's like a 50 year old he's a grown man
he's a grown man but uh yeah prank call
exactly
okay so thank you very much that was uh
who were you in the 90s i think that was
great i'm glad you had such distinct
answers most people i guess
you knew what you wanted of course you
knew okay okay and my last question my
last thing to end this and before i do
thank you for being here this has been
fun yeah this has been i don't even know
how long we've been here but this has
been a fun episode thank you thank you
that joint actually did make me feel
different good that was awesome yeah i
noticed it gave you energy yeah it woke
me up you're up yeah it was like [ __ ]
lovely i gotta start putting some
different i guess i'm always looking for
things like that because you see me you
know and my energy is i'm trying to
bring it i need to and then down of
course at night going to bed please but
during the day if i'm going to go film
or something i'm going to smoke i got to
find something i can smoke that's not
going to
put me to bed yeah no one wants to see
me do a video from bed yeah that
wouldn't be good at all like i gotcha
let me show you this new product no no
no you want me alive and awake and i
want to be that way and then when you've
gotten all that energy out then you
crash the [ __ ] out and do it again the
next time i gotta try i gotta try and
smoke the same thing all day every day
no change i never did this
that's why i got to change i have tried
this helped me a lot i like that i like
the feeling it gave me yeah i'll get
your mom or i am uh surprised i gotta be
honest because like i told you off
camera i don't like lemon yeah so it's
good okay here's my question ready okay
yeah ready we came in with this and i
said
i i and a lot of people other people
would think of it more of think of you
more as the willy wonka
factory of smoking products you are a
personality behind
the product
that's how i see it right
and i put this this way when i was
writing up a question like how am i
going to wear this
are you actively or is it ever a thought
in your brain to find a charlie and
grandpa to take over all your stuff so
you don't have to do it anymore oh yeah
all the time yeah yeah yeah all the time
all the time man really yeah oh yeah i
love what i'm doing but like someone's
got to run this [ __ ] and i can't sell it
that's not an option there people are
people out there that tried to buy
before a big tobacco
a company a very large tobacco company
tried to buy me and that was a turning
point in my life when i realized that i
couldn't sell to them i thought about
all the alcoholianos i thought about all
the history all my people my my family
everybody and how
hurt
it would i'd be the pain i'd be sending
upon them because when that guy buys it
it's over man for all of them eventually
they're all becoming these little
servants and it's not going to be good
it's not gonna be good and there was no
way i could do it there's not enough
money that exists in this planet to get
me to do that so it can't so that went
out
um
instead because if you when you love
your people you can't sell them
you can't
you know yeah so that's gone so the only
realistic way out for me
because eventually i'm gonna be gone is
either my incredibly smart beautiful
amazing daughter steps up and does this
which would be amazing
or someone else does
i don't know if she has any interest in
this whatsoever she might not
and then okay what happens
what happens then
you know you got to find someone to take
it over you got to find charlie grandpa
is awesome i'll hang out with them all
the time but you got to find your
charlie so that you can
go do go relax and go spend some time
there's some mornings i just want to get
up and smoke and go back to [ __ ] to bed
i love doing that sometimes i'd like to
do a little more of that a lot more of
it actually i really would i want to go
back to ethiopia more
my goal like when i travel places now is
i want to be there for for as long as
possible so when i go to alkoy i want to
be there for ideally two months just
stay i know where i want to eat i know i
want to get immersed more in the culture
i want to connect deeper i want to be
there be there not as a tourist not as
someone who's in there for a little bit
and leaves i want to be like the whole
[ __ ] town to know my little details
you know what i mean yeah i want to be
part of the community for real
everywhere i go i want it to be like
that
so i'll tell you what so when i was
really starting to travel more starting
to hit around all the different places
and seeing some incredible spots
i realized
oh man
i wish i could cut off my pinky for real
and grow another josh
and leave him here [ __ ] yeah i could
leave him as an expat in the philippines
and he could live an incredible life
here he would have such impact and such
he would live such an amazing life if i
would just could leave a josh here in
the philippines in bali
another josh he could live here his
whole life the impact he would have on
that was an orphanage that were one of
the primary sponsors of the impact he
would have the good he could do in
ethiopia let me go off another finger
for there of course that josh that's a
really important josh man that josh has
got had some serious work to do he could
do some incredible stuff with his life
anywhere i've been even in russia cut
off my thumb leave leave it josh in
russia live that expat life josh wow i
don't know what that would be like
in spain of course everywhere i want to
leave a josh
and then at the end of my life bring
everyone together and share all the
knowledge and all those lives together
and feel them all as one
that was like a weird [ __ ] up dream i
had
it would just be because it was so much
so weird [ __ ] up it's true man
it was so inspiring it's just a weird
[ __ ] up treat i love it because it's
coming from here yeah
it's um
when i realized like how much beauty
there is to be lived
when i re when you're there in a place
and you realize like oh my god
imagine if you lived here imagine if you
stayed when you imagined it what that
would be like and there's so many places
throughout this entire planet that are
just like that
and
living any one of those lives would be
magical special and incredible in its
own way and then you're back here living
the life that you're actually living
and you
so many roads and so many incredible
roads and i've seen them all in a way
i want everyone to see that because if
you can feel that
you realize there is so much more to be
lived and hopefully this inspires you to
live it you can go live one of those
lives that i was unable to because
they're incredible man they're journeys
and that would be amazing
[ __ ] josh
josh always making me think deep and
insightful in a good way
[ __ ] man i just thought of so much stuff
right now when you're talking
like what
places i've never seen yeah i would just
flash through my head of things i've
seen on youtube not just seeing him with
a tourist though yeah being there it's
live a different place
yeah you've done enough it's your time
to go do that i get i see exactly what
you're saying
if i could just find charlie
wow yeah hopefully that motherfucker's
watching right now i wish i would so you
are actively looking for that person to
hand it down to gotta let the genie out
of the bottle sometimes let me go oh my
god
josh
the things you say man that was the most
relatable [ __ ] i've ever heard i thought
about was robin williams really
oh no
oh everybody just got emotional at home
like i love robin williams
man that was amazing that's really all
right
for everyone out there
you are actively looking to step away
and live your life and do different
things
that would free up so much of your life
to do more
of things you were saying like with the
with the giving raw giving and all that
i mean
24 7. yeah you that now that's your life
great goal to have
super good goal to have that's the goal
you want to relax a little bit and also
help 100 times more 100 times more at
least
yeah really make that impact i mean like
yeah like where it's it's at that level
of superhero status you know where
you've got the team the crack team we're
not just going to fix it we're going to
fix it right we're going to make sure
it's protected this time like you ain't
getting in here man no [ __ ] way
you're like wow okay
yeah love it
lives tony stark for real
get out of here i've heard people go
fools like robert danny jr like he kind
of does look like robert i never thought
about it
you're gonna love tony stark live
imagine just imagine that though
if you did that in a way of positivity
and giving back where it was like you
didn't just go into help you went in to
help yeah again you did it it was like
oh unstoppable
that would be a man that's a real
superhero lives it's closer you're gonna
get to it man
yeah great goals to have i love that
before we get out of here can you tell
me something
what is the best way for people to help
everything you're doing
okay well i've got lots of good ways
at the moment we're actually doing a
giving back nft
really
i posted about it before um i think it's
uh raw nft i gotta find the i'll give
you the link yeah but we're doing this
nft that really i make nothing from it
it's for my side it's all giving back
so i've got that we have giving proceeds
go
straight to the our side of the proceeds
because of course there's some fees on
the thing that we don't get but our like
i get nothing like me and my whole fam
get nothing from this this is just to
give back to do more wells and to do
more things that need to be done in
ethiopia i'm trying to do a bigger
project to make up for the one that
i lost gotcha so
which i'm going to do one way or another
it will be done it'll be done right
so there's that at rawgiving.com this is
kind of an interesting thing that's
metamorphosized in something more than
it was really ever i ever thought it
would be
it's a website where
people go and let's say you wanted to
buy this free tree case or this grinder
when you
buy it you're not really buying it
you're making a donation directly to in
this case it's water as life or the wine
to water because the money goes directly
to them all of what you did so if you're
paying
five dollars plus five dollars for
shipping ten bucks for this the ten
bucks goes directly to them and then we
just turn around and send this to you
for free
so i get nothing we never handle the
money and i do this for a reason
um
and so we just here take the grinder
thank you so much for making that
donation it's just a thank you
i'm doing it like that because
i'm trying to get the receiver of this
to get the feeling that i have
when i first started really giving back
it's this feeling of giving this feeling
of realizing that you're actually making
a difference this because it's part of
our humanity
it feels good to give back to people it
feels good to help somebody you see
somebody starving on the corner and you
show up with food and help them you're
doing it because it's not just to help
that person because it gives you a good
feeling it's programmed into our dna to
do this you just got to feel that a
little more it's addictive you know and
i want to share that feeling with you so
that you'll do more of it in your own
life
so that as you become more successful if
somebody is sitting here and they've
listened this freaking far into this
podcast of two dudes smoking and
rambling for hours
and i can tell you that's a really
special person to begin with that's
someone who is truly trying to make it
they're listening to the words that you
and i are saying because they're trying
to get advice because they're trying to
elevate themselves and bring themselves
to a better place there's no one else
who's going to listen this far unless
you're really at that level there's no
one else
so with all that being said
the odds of you making it especially
after listening to you and me ramble for
this long is now higher
and if you make it and when you do
because you must
you have to give back for real
that's the deal
better than i've ever done higher
percentages
come on it feels good to do it find ways
and it's not ideally it's not in the way
that is the closest to you it's not by
helping out your best friend with a
mortgage payment instead it's by helping
somebody you know nothing about who
speaks a different language than you and
living in a far away land because it's
cheaper to save his life for a hundred
bucks than it is to help your friend
with something else and you realize how
much i want to help my friend which is
awesome maybe i'll do both
the most important thing is saving that
life let me do that first and then i'll
help you too we'll get it all done
somehow
but it's this beautiful feeling of
giving and i want to share it so that
people do it more
i hope it works but it's what we're
trying to do
and that's all at rawgivy.com
rawgiving.com
you got some good karma coming boy
i was waiting for marty i was waiting
for a line from my buddy drops these
perfect lines in here in these silence
moments
that's all i was looking for it's a huge
giant wave that's been building up for
so long like that's what the universe
likes yeah it does it really it just
trickles down it just trickles to the
next person the next person and what i
believe is every time you get a gift
like when something amazing happens and
you have a huge success you pause for a
moment and you listen because if you
just listen a little bit
with that gift comes a request
and if you honor the request
if you somehow end up
for me it was when the truck drove
through and this is not a place i was
meant to be the sisters of mother
teresa's main hospital not at the baba
ethiopia the gates open up and i pull in
and realize oh [ __ ]
this this situation is bad bad and you
then as it goes on and you learn how bad
is you realize that you have the ability
to help in a way that no one else can
and sure there are other people that
were supposed to and you can go down
that path and blame it on them well they
were so that when they were so help but
in the end you could help these people
man and then you do it
and you actually do it like really do it
not just uh no
now you've honored the universe's
request
and you'll receive an even bigger gift
and with that bigger gift might come
another request and that's okay always
honor it
you get you give back you receive more
it really goes like this this energetic
wave you were talking about it's all
real man
energy is the real thing the stars are
emitting it you and i are burning it
right now as we sit here it's the way it
is that light bulb is emitting it too
it's real it comes in ebbs and flows man
it's like waves on an ocean
just listen to it a little bit more and
then hopefully we'll all do better
let's go
there's another trailer moment
oh my god i wanted the slow clap
where's that one
where's that on the snowboard marty the
slow clap
josh you're dropping knowledge on here i
love it i hope everyone out here is
absorbing this
because i'm sitting here and just
i love this right now that's what the
show is all about and how many times
like josh
it's just this is different like there's
something i don't know what it is yeah
something that's why you've been so
successful though i think you attract
all this good energy and positivity and
it just
comes back but you also give it back
like the request thing yeah of course
you can't just sit here and go knowledge
it's mine i hate it that's wrong
you can't do that we are doing too much
of that lately
and we need to do less of that
as a people as a people all of us yeah
we all need to i do it too we all fall
victim to this
it's this feeling you get of like well
what if i need it later how can i give
this away i only have so much of it and
if if i give it this away what if i need
it it's this feeling and you just let go
anyway
you're like well
[ __ ] it
exactly
if you can help man [ __ ] help yeah so
rawgiving.com is there anything else uh
i mean it's rothantik.com yes for our
for but they already know who like by
now you you know hopefully the products
i think we've gotten big enough where
they're available most spots oh it's
it's
every headshot i've ever walked into in
my entire existence
here it is yeah just go to the head shop
guys and some of the stuff i don't make
that much of it and it's something
purposeful i want to get better the next
time and better and better and better
some people don't have head shops in
their spot okay so it's authentic yeah
then you go to authentic.com that's at
least from there you can find out where
to get where to get anything and what
where what places sell it yeah there's
some great places online we don't sell
direct we just yeah it's not direct
consumer yeah
at least it's the links there so for
everyone asking
go ahead and check that out yeah there's
some great spot and and hopefully we've
helped you enjoy your smoke a little
more than before
well while i'm trying to make everybody
laugh and all these stories and videos
i'm always smoking raws so thank you for
helping me
thank you guys
it's weird the little trickle-down
effect that's happening right now
great i'll keep that that's that's my
quote that's what i get
josh on instagram on everything it's
rock and roll
r-a-w-k-a-n-d-r-o-l-l that's on
instagram rock with a w in the middle
guys rock rock [ __ ]
okay man you've been here for a very
long time thank you for sitting thank
you for changing your flight so you can
come hang out with us i appreciate that
a lot thank you very much
people have been asking non-stop and i
hope you guys have
this is a long episode
i'm gonna say it's over two and a half
hours at least yeah and i hope you guys
enjoyed it and i know you guys are still
sitting here in the premiere we premiere
these live and we sit in the chat and
stuff so we get to talk to people as
it's happening it's wow so awesome
that's awesome it is very fun so peop i
know everybody's very excited josh thank
you so much for being here spreading
this positivity on this damn channel
you're welcome thank you for being here
thank you for having me sir appreciate
you congratulations thank you i am so
[ __ ] proud of you honestly man i
really am i appreciate it it's been a
i've known you i think almost this whole
time yeah so
thank you thank you for all the advice
and everything appreciate you dude
appreciate you too josh thank you so
much you're killing it man i i just want
to see you hit the freaking moon thank
you oh it's coming we're gonna go we're
going as hard as we can this is a good
year i'm excited
guys this has been the josh kesselman
episode i don't know
how long we've been here 10 hours
marty thank you so much for being thank
you sir this was a great episode very
inspirational and lots of gems for
everybody thank you yes lots of lots of
them i've
our editor cole get ready for some clips
a lot of clips coming out of this one
there's so much
and like you said i want to get anything
negative and it's the best thing anybody
could do like you know no no why even
talk about it let's stay on the
positives yeah you said that like five
times and then watch you revert
it's great do it to myself yeah i do to
myself you know what i don't care let's
move on yeah who cares i i try to do
this as much as i can you do it
incredibly as instagram would take down
your [ __ ] i would talk to you about it
and the things that were coming out of
your mouth blew my mind man you were so
good about it i've never seen another
human being do as well as you did with
it you turned it right into positivity
and inspired the [ __ ] out of me i got to
tell you honestly i couldn't believe how
well you did with that anyone else would
have been taken down except for you i
would have been taken down and you were
not
you didn't let it stop you the day after
they deleted his youtube the day we were
supposed to hit a million subscribers
that next morning he's like what's up
[ __ ] it [ __ ] you right
it was just inspirational to me it's
like whenever when they come at me i
think this i think of you
yeah one day
one day we're going to be talking about
a whole different part of the subject
going remember when that used to happen
oh it's gonna be awesome one day we're
gonna be left alone because you guys
gotta remember even you get shadow man
oh yeah even josh
take down my account all the time just
they just it's frowned upon and until it
is we'll still be here and always
remember this episode right here just
come back and watch it if you're
starting a business if you're in a hard
time in life if you're in a rough patch
if you're financially [ __ ] up come
watch this and remember like i said to
my 10 year old self it'll get better
just stick with it get better and you'll
be okay
thank you so much for doing this man
thank you thank you so much for hanging
out guys this has been the josh gasman
episode this is marty o'neil this is
josh everybody at raw thank you guys so
much for creating my favorite paper in
the world uh thank you guys so much this
has been the dopes usual podcast have a
dope ass day
yeah
that's a good episode man
yo i really hope people
absorb a lot of things you said
perfect
[Music]